it appears that covid mandates are back
at least at some Universities at
Hollywood studio and we're seeing more
calls for the return of mask mandates
and for people to get their booster
shots Joe Biden is advising everybody
got to get your new booster forbes.com
is saying there's going to be a new
covet booster coming out this fall and
you should talk to your doctor about
when you should get your new vaccine
Forbes is saying that doctors are
advising you wait for the new one that's
coming out this fall
there's a lot of reasons to believe that
the lockdowns will return government
expenditures and as such and we've often
talked about what the Democrats would
need to win an election against Trump
considering Trump lost by only about 42
000 votes across three states yeah
they're going to need an excuse to lock
people in their homes to enforce mail-in
voting to shut down people's
entertainment to keep them hyper focused
I don't know that it'll work this time
but we'll talk about that I've also got
a bunch of other news Donald Trump is
going to turn himself in on Thursday
we'll talk a little bit about that the
oh this one's good Trump has launched a
vice presidential debate website mocking
the GOP debates and uh we'll get into
that plus you've got people coming after
Oliver Anthony because of a quote that
he gave to Fox News so I definitely want
to talk about where we're at culturally
I think I think Oliver Anthony is
absolutely fantastic and the quote he
gave that everyone's ragging on him for
totally out of context they are trying
to smear the guy because he's doing
something good before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com to buy
Casper coffee uh support The Show by
buying our coffee we sponsor ourselves
we have a whole bunch of different types
we've got ground coffee and whole bean
it is apparent that the ground sells way
better than whole I get it not everybody
has a coffee grinder but some people
really do want the whole bean we got
K-Cups as well and you can join the cast
Brew Coffee Club you will get three bags
of coffee either ground or whole bean
every single month also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member so that you can watch the members
only uncensored show Monday through
Thursday we'll have one of those up for
you tonight at 10 p.m where you as
members can submit questions and
potentially call in the show to talk to
us and our guest so smash that like
button share the show right now if you
can take that URL post it everywhere
that really does help if that's uh if
that's all you can do it would be
greatly appreciated Word of Mouth helps
podcasts grow the most and you can
follow the show at timcast IRL joining
us tonight to talk about all of this and
so much more is Natalie Winters hi thank
you so much for having me it's always an
honor to be back and to be with you guys
absolutely who are you I am the co-host
of Steve bannon's war room and I also
run the affiliated website which is
warroom.org where I occasionally dabble
in investigative reporting about all
things China in this case covered
lockdowns would basically how the Deep
state is lying to you right on thanks
for hanging out we got Phil Labonte
hello everybody I am Phil Levante Leads
Here the heavy metal band uh All That
Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary today I am wearing
my Hawaii hat in uh in solidarity with
uh those people that uh have had their
lives destroyed in Hawaii you see the
video of them flicking off Joe Biden and
screaming at a lot of it and they have
every right to be pissed every right
that's another story that we have for
you guys Joe Biden falling asleep during
the meeting with the victims falling
asleep come on Wow is it true that
someone withheld water from the fire
department this is the store this is
this is how I understand it yes um I was
listening to Tulsi gabbard talking
talking to uh Glenn Beck on a podcast
today and she was saying that
um there's a lot of issues and fights
over water rights on Maui you know water
they don't have a lot of a lot of places
get water if the stream's not running
it's not raining there ain't water there
there's not like a bunch of you're
surrounded by sea water so
um but yes there was issues I don't know
the details so I don't want to say what
it was but there was some kind of issue
that caused uh caused them to have to
slow getting water out to to put the
fires up but the the wind was going at
100 miles an hour they were talking
about the actual fires were progressing
at like 60 miles an hour 70 knots crazy
I mean you're you're done like you're
not out running that obviously it's like
you you're there's nowhere you're going
to get inside to get away from it
because the buildings are all you know
it's like you are just people were
jumping in the water yeah you know it
looks like a thousand people are dead
and it looks like a lot of that thousand
are gonna be kids it's a horse kids that
got sent home from school because of the
fire and they didn't have anywhere to go
and they burned alive did Jesus come on
well hey hi everyone Joe was tired man
come on yeah
took 10 days to get the Navy involved
someone said that they don't think that
it was
um they think that the reason that he
didn't get out there is because he's
sick and he can't make the trip that's
why he had to stop at Tahoe because it's
an 11 hour flight from DC even if he's
got the IV marks on his hand around yeah
we'll talk about it we'll talk well I I
also hey everyone Ian cross and I've got
this this Crystal that Luke gradkowski
uh got for me apparently he charged it
in the Pacific Ocean himself looks like
quartz crystal we bought it from an old
man on the on the sidewalk in Tijuana
thanks old man and uh he was he was like
we were like how much is this and he's
like uh how much you got and we're like
I don't know and then he like looks at
our hand we see we're holding a bunch of
pesos and he's like yeah that and we're
like yeah sure give us the rock give us
the rock we're with it then Joe Biden
and then Luke was like we can't just
give a DMS we have to charge it in the
ocean yeah so we walked into we walked
right by the uh where the border wall is
and Luke put it in the water to charge
it up oh that's what I'm talking about
that get that Mexican-American energy
thanks I thought I thought you were
talking about like a Tesla shark
cool I may take it off because it's kind
of heavy around my neck it's like a
ghost Stone there's ghosts in that rock
there Ian I will to haunted we got surge
pressing buttons yeah I like Ian
Santeria crystal that's pretty cool
um what's up guys I'm serge.com I'm
ready for the show to start Let's uh all
right let's go ladies and gentlemen
here's the story from today from CBS
News Atlanta based Morris Brown College
says they are reinstating covid mask
mandates Lionsgate reinstates mask made
it in parts of Santa Monica office
following covet outbreak and don't
forget the New York Post amid summer
surge of new covet variant should we be
wearing masks no you've also no you've
also got a bunch of stories about uh
Biden advocating for people to start
getting their vaccines once again we've
got a new vaccine variant being released
this fall according to Forbes but it
seems very likely at least right now
that kovid mandates will be returning
now the story started with none other
than Alex Jones who said that he spoke
with the TSA whistleblower who said that
they had been called into a meeting to
discuss the new covid policies in by
October they will be in full-blown covid
policy mandate Etc
I don't know that's guaranteed because
often when there's a big backlash when
we talk about things when other shows
talk about it then these stories might
disappear because they're worried about
a big splash shocking people so maybe
maybe nothing happens
but I do got to say I don't know what
else the Democrats can do to try to win
in 2024 because they desperately need
that procedural help when it comes to
Universal mail and voting
but you could Supply a good candidate
that would help Robert F Kennedy I don't
know if he really has a chance in hell
the problem with the Democratic party is
they have super delegates so they can
just pick the candidate so it doesn't
really matter who votes Yahoo and just
decide that that's we're going to run
this time so nice Democratic Republic
well it's like you know the Democrats of
the Harlem Globetrotters and the
Republicans of the Washington generals
it's pretty accurate I think so yeah
uh Michelle Obama doesn't want to run I
hear well why do you keep bringing
Michelle Obama I've heard that she wants
or they wanted to run they Wicked wanted
to run because she would win but but she
doesn't want to do it you don't think so
I I would have I would have agreed that
a couple years ago I'm not so convinced
today Trump got 75 million votes in
2020. that is more than he he got more
like more votes than any sitting uh
president any incumbent and historically
I believe this is true a president who
received more votes in their re-election
has never lost until Trump there were a
lot of things that affected 2020 but the
most important factor here a Democratic
party well for sure I mean judges
Governors policy changes lawsuits Etc
but when all of these never trumpers and
Democrats are saying Trump can't win
actually now the Democrats are saying
Trump can win and probably will win and
you get these never trumpers being like
no no Trump can't win even when
Democrats are like actually it's looking
pretty good for Trump Donald Trump lost
by only about 42 000 votes in three
states yeah he can easily remedy that
and especially with Joe Biden's failures
my concern with his covet these coveted
lockdowns not so much my concern but my
thinking on this
I'm not so convinced it'll get as bad as
many people think because
Joe Biden's president
the Democrats have the Senate if they
start locking things down and forcing
mandates on people it's Joe Biden's
fault maybe that's opening the door to
bring in a Gavin Newsom or something
because they can't run Biden but this
will not help Joe Biden I think the
easiest way to kind of view all the
actions that Democrats do is through the
Paradigm of obviously accusing your
enemies of what you're guilty of and I
think for so long they accused Donald
Trump of you know conspiring to overturn
the election results and sort of more
broadly the Republican party that's what
they did in 2020 and even from the onset
of Trump's campaign in 2016 right it was
Russia foreign collusion and I really
think that if you look at the pandemic
through that lens in other words they
use the mail-in voting they used the
pandemic as an excuse to allow a bunch
of money from you know these Mark
Zuckerberg line groups to really change
the way that elections were run to
really turn it into nothing that
resembles a free and fair election and I
think that is why they have been going
so hard accusing Donald Trump in the
Trump campaign of trying to alter
election results and conspiracy sees to
you know overturn elections because in
reality that's what they're
fundamentally trying to do and I think
one of the ways they do it is the Loft
bear with the indictments and stuff like
that but I think these covid-19 mandates
it's another form of lawfare that is
almost more nefarious I think that the
the we were talking earlier um about the
the point just being to get mail-in
ballots out I think that the lockdowns
are just going to be
I think that the government and stuff
will say okay you should lock down or
there will be lockdowns I think there's
going to be a large vast majority of
Americans are going to ignore it and
then the government's just going to
behave as if
everyone's doing what they say they're
going to do they're gonna act like
everyone's listening like everyone's
locking down and everyone's gonna be
like it's so weird that they keep saying
that this is at like we should lock down
but nobody does anything and they're
going to use it as an excuse so that way
they can mail out ballots again so that
way they get the balance into people's
hands I think 98 I agree with you I
would tweak it only slightly
I think what they may end up doing is
they'll say we realize that you know
hard lockdown policies were were widely
condemned and so listening to the will
of the people we are going to roll out
our guidelines that you lock down but no
no this time No One's Gonna Force you
and then because that was under Trump
that you were forced Joe Biden and they
can still use it as an excuse to send
out the ballots absolutely and they'll
say and because our guidelines are as
such we'll be sending out mail-in
ballots to every single home in the
state well and remember too that I think
it was either this week or next week
there was a lot of consternation over
the fact that Joe Biden was potentially
going to declare a climate emergency and
use it as a pretext to kind of Institute
climate lockdowns and whatnot so frankly
I always thought that it would be more
likely that they would bring about the
second round of lockdowns via the like
climate change or other kind of
Manufacturers I don't know how that
works because the the first lockdowns
people would like myself included gave
the government the best gave them the
benefit of the doubt said okay we're
gonna say if you if the stuff that
you're saying is true it could be a
problem so we're going to give you the
benefit of that how on Earth
are they going to convince people that
are adults that are that are 35 and
older that have been seeing climate
alarmism for their entire life how are
they going to get those people to
actually believe that this new issue
that they're bringing up is actually
worth locking down for and you have to
stop how do you how do they do it easy
how smog
When the Smoke came here I was messed up
I woke up my throat was on fire and I
was I was short of breath are we seeding
the clouds together are we starting
fires to get smoke I mean I'm just
saying they're going to use the smoke
problem as a pretext for we need to do
something about this now I'm not saying
they're starting fires I'm saying
they've already said the smoke is going
to come back this fall surprise surprise
yeah because of their because their
their particular policies that like
allowed for these rainforests like not
reinforest but Forest to build up alone
yeah
literally said the Maui fires are
because of climate change so they
obviously are using all these crises
it's going to have to get widespread but
not so Extreme as Maui but when you have
that's that smoke was brutal it was
really really bad and uh wait we had to
put bring the chickens inside because
the chickens are low to the ground we
put them in a shed we put them in a shed
we had we had to get some kind of like
air conditioning because it was too hot
but the uh you need something to put
them inside to deal with the
particulates because they can die
you get enough of those events where
people keep panicking and people are
getting sick and people going to the
hospital and then they're gonna say we
have to do something about climate
change and I mean even look at Hurricane
Hillary in California I'm from
California my parents are there they
sent me videos and I sort of joked them
I was like it just looks like it's
raining and not I'm sure people were
injured hurricanes look like you know no
one no one died in California right I
think I'm correct and that one person
maybe died in Mexico but my parents said
you went to the grocery stores every
single thing except for sliced white
bread was gone and I think that shows
you how the media if they really can
manufacture a narrative around some you
know looming and pending natural
disaster whether it's the smog a
hurricane this that even if in reality
it's not actually as intense as they
want it to be they can sort of like a
social engineer a reaction or a response
to it that elicits almost in some ways a
reaction that's worse than her I agree
but I got to respond to this
crazy right hurricanes are just drizzle
at Hurricane Sandy in New York there was
no rain at all and this is a mistake I
made when I was in Hurricane Irene in
Virginia uh that uh don't get me wrong
hurricanes can't have rain and yeah
there was some rain for Sandy so when I
was in San Diego tonight I'm standing
near the stock exchange in the financial
district watching Manhattan flood and
the waters are rising and we're putting
sandbags out and all there was no strong
wind and there was no rain at this time
and all you heard was a because the wind
was going above the buildings and being
uh refracted from the buildings when I
was in Irene no strong rain at all and I
was shocked and I was like where's the
rain so I see all these videos from
people and they're like this is the
great hurricane it's just drizzle and
then you have this massive flooding
sweeping through the LA River and man
there's this video of these guys jogging
and they it the the water is Raging next
to them as they're on this this walking
path and then they come to this uh this
water that's flowing rapidly across the
path and they up and Skip through it and
I'm like that's how you die because you
put one foot down it pushes you over and
you get swept into that massive raging
Storm current and then you're dead the
issue with hurricanes is always storm
surge and I also want to add we know
that the hurricane in Los Angeles wasn't
climate change it was the wrath of God
over the Dragons I'm kidding but it is
it is crazy to see we've got uh the news
is the most important factor in whether
or not you get a reaction
if the media and and even we are guilty
of this and everyone's guilty of this
the media dictates The Narrative and the
story they all their journalists will
just start talking about the same thing
and then all the conservatives will come
out and react to it so when they decide
the big story is going to be these fires
everyone's like oh the fire's all the
fires and then you're going to get more
and more news where they're going to put
the smog death counter and they're gonna
yup and then people and they're gonna be
like we have to do something about it
and then all of the Democrats and all
the neolibs are going to be like why
aren't you locking down it's the it's
the smog it's coming it's climate change
I believe it's entirely possible I
imagine there will be a lot more uh
interpersonal conflict with people on
the street with people saying why you
know when it comes to people that are
complaining about oh why aren't you
locking down and then the the people
that don't want to lock down don't want
to wear a mask they're not going to be
quiet about it anymore like again people
gave the benefit of the doubt the first
time in 2020. they're not going to give
the benefit of the doubt anymore yeah 15
days to school
as soon as someone says something about
oh why aren't you wearing your mask
someone's gonna be like because I want
to get you know whatever they're gonna
just you know give a bunch of lip and
it's going to be a lot of Confrontation
I've got a feeling the people not all of
them but for the most part if people are
scared into wearing masks by TV shows
those are those are cowardly people
that's that's a behavior of cowards and
cowards aren't very likely to come out
on the street and challenge you for not
wearing a mask they absolutely if
there's if they're afraid then they're
going to be like that person is
endangering me and it's going to be a
fear response when they go up to them
and confront them it's not going to be
about asserting themselves for dominance
it's going to be you're going to hurt me
that's that's and that's always what the
what the case was when it came to the
people that were like oh you know you're
not wearing your mask it's always like
you should be wearing your mask because
you're gonna hurt me
I uh I'm I liken back to 2020 and I
think you just said it 15 days to slow
spread the only reason in hell I would
ever lock my country down is because
there was some sort of flesh-eating
virus tearing through the population you
never do that to your country unless it
was the last ditch effort circumstance
that you have no other choice you lost
running water you lost soap if in those
situations maybe because you that that
is the recipe to destroy your country is
to shut it down don't do that again and
don't make people put dirty
masks on
nice I'm sick of it man I'm sick
of it I will not do it again
thank you
I wonder how many people feel exactly
the same way yeah I agree well you know
we're out in West Virginia so we came
out here because we were in New Jersey
and it started getting really intense
there was talk locally about shutting
down the bridges out of New Jersey and I
was like um maybe
wait and find out if I'm trapped on this
peninsula so we uh we were working on
setting up the new studio and we were
like let's just go down early and we'll
figure it out and we'll we'll make it
work the problem was the internet wasn't
set up and so we had to use this like
janky internet but I was like don't know
don't care don't want to be in New
Jersey anymore so we came out here and
then surprise surprise you know the
interesting thing about coming out to
West Virginia we're in the tri-state
which is Maryland Virginia West Virginia
the further you go towards the cities
the more you have to wear masks you go
into Maryland they're nuts you cross
into West Virginia ain't nobody wearing
masks I mean like some people would you
might see some people somewhere but for
the most part nobody was so I'm just
saying you know when I say get out of
cities it's not just about whether or
not you'll be safe it's about whether
you be comfortable but if you want to
live in those lockdowns I I I I look
if the government announces climate
change lockdowns you know all these
Democrats are going to be the
krakensteins are going to make the the
the the the rational argument on Twitter
to engage in conversation about why the
climate change lockdowns are absolutely
required and why Joe Biden is right to
Institute them they will fall in line in
two seconds do they mention climate
change lockdowns or is this just an idea
let's see they're talking about it
because if you remember no no not the
krakensteins I'm saying they're an
example of they often come out with the
establishment narrative and try to make
a reasonable conversation about why it's
correct they don't they don't come out
like most Libs screaming and like
you know they're just like I'd like to
have a discussion about it it's I mean I
respect it but I'm just saying they will
be doing it I am more likely to
decide that a new pandemic is more
dangerous and I would lock down for a
nude pandemic than I am for a climate
change Locker oh yeah like it would take
actual like I would have to be it would
be forced they'd have to be like you you
have to leave you can't come in they'd
have to kick me out of everywhere I'm
not staying in my house you know I I
think the uh the initial lockdowns the
reason why we all gave the benefit of
the doubt to the government was because
they were talking about this novel
respiratory virus with a high mortality
rate and so we're all like we got to
figure out what's going on
now that hindsight is 2020 we all look
back like oh what a waste of time that
was so dumb but yeah we were seeing
these these videos of people and China
collapsing in the street and people were
getting scar tissue in their lungs I
think the alpha strain of covid was
really really really bad and then what
happens is
this at least this is how the corporate
press has described it over time the
more serious strains
cease because they cause too much damage
to the host and limit its ability to
spread somebody who's so sick they're
incapacitated can't spread the virus so
the weaker versions that start emerging
keep people somewhat active feeling a
little under the weather and that more
easily spread so over time the variants
will become weaker but more contagious
or I guess that's how they described it
uh yeah so at the time when they were
saying look at what we're saying we were
seeing very very serious stuff I can I
can respect that nobody knew and I can
say now we know and now we should be uh
more careful about how we enact these
things that being said we've talked
about it on this show you brought it up
Ian what if it was an Airborne Ebola
that's what I'm talking about and then
we're like okay that's actually a really
good question I still think you have the
responsibility to quarantine if you want
to and I put my faith and trust in our
government and our world's governments
during covid because I thought maybe it
was going to be a flesh eating bacteria
and I was like I'm not gonna play God on
this one but after the 15 days ended and
they kept going for month like another
15 days and another 15 days it was like
and then I found out about the bio labs
in in Wuhan that Anthony fauci's
involved in I'm like okay so they what
they built this thing and then it got
loose is that the story now this is
disgusting I'm not saying there can't be
another bio weapon let loose on people
but like it's not worth destroying the
global economy because of it you've got
to take care of yourself thank you Tim
that's a good point you have to take
care of yourself first you need a
healthy body you need to eat healthy you
need to get enough sunlight and enough
sleep you need to get soap and drink
enough water and if if you're hearing in
the news that they're saying there's an
Airborne Ebola with a 50 mortality rate
it should still be your choice whether
or not you want to go out and go to work
the government forcing you to stay home
is stupid though I know you can't leave
now if there's an Airborne but again
we're talking about something that's
very extreme there's an Airborne Ebola
people you're gonna see people you're
going to see people literally bleeding
out of their eyes and you're gonna it's
gonna be real easy to make the decision
ain't nobody gonna be like lemon think
about it do I need to go get them smokes
not no everyone's staying home you know
actually but you see these open-air drug
markets
these videos out of Philadelphia in Los
Angeles oh yeah skid row and stuff dude
I imagine if if there's a pandemic like
a more serious one that gets to that
level of like 10 20 30 there's going to
be videos of all of these people being
like zombie was nasty when they couldn't
before they knew leprosy was like just a
bacteria that eats flesh before they had
soap really they couldn't wash it off
that's basically the Cure I they they
would touch people's bodies and they
would get the bacteria on their own skin
and then their skin would start to get
eaten and they thought it was contagious
like so they would quarantine lepers but
like leprosy is not that easy just
reading about it last night oh cool I
gotta read a Super Chat normally we wait
until the end for super chats but it's
too good chaser says Ian just broke the
die to reveal a 21 inside yes yes
I love that I love I love how the saying
hindsight is 20 20 like literally
applies to covid because it literally
was the year 2020. I know isn't that
weird I actually I can't take credit for
that I had a hair stylist who was like
super hippy dippy and into all this
stuff and she was giving be all these
sayings oh my gosh but I think what
enrages me the most and I obviously did
a lot of reporting on Anthony fauci and
the bio labs and the Wuhan Institute of
virology is that this very same group
Eco Health Alliance was sort of
funneling the taxpayer funds to the
Wuhan Institute of virology they have
continued to receive multi-million
dollar grants from the federal
government even from the Department of
Defense particularly working on believe
it or not the grants are under the
weapons of mass destruction category
sort of in the bio weapon territory and
they've renewed even that really
controversial Grant um from Nya the
National Institute of allergy and
infectious diseases to Eco Health the
same Grant they were working with the
Chinese Communist party-run lab on these
you know manipulating back coronaviruses
and also it's so enraging because you
hear all these Western scientists still
sort of championing uh the crusade of
you know oh we need to partner with
Scientists in China who are all under
the thumb of the Chinese Communist party
and it just seems like the establishment
has not learned their lesson at all when
it comes to pandemic prevention and I
think it goes back to what we were all
saying and really what I think is at the
core of our frustration with these
lockdowns and these mandates is that
these alleged people who are supposed to
be stopping these pandemics who are in
the business of pandemic prevention also
concurrently seem to be the very same
people who are benefiting when the
pandemics hit because when they
Institute the lockdowns the mandates it
just increases their power right it just
increases their ability to basically
control society and I think for me
looking at it through again my very
Niche lens of like the Wuhan Institute
of virology and who's funding all these
entities they haven't learned their
lessons so when you see the same voices
on the mainstream media telling us we
need to lock down and always ending
their segments with the you know wagging
their fingers saying you need to wear a
mask it's like you know shut up you guys
haven't learned your lesson I usually
don't get fired up but it's just these
people are so full of it and if they
think they can do it again good luck
YouTube has their New World Health
Organization policy I guess they got rid
of the covid policy and now they're
doing the straight up World Health
Organization policy where you can't defy
them or whatever but they should well
this will be interesting to see YouTube
said YouTube launched their World Health
Organization saying the quiet part out
loud yeah yeah they're saying it used to
be the covid policy and now it's just
the who policy or whatever so we'll see
what new rules they start rolling out
randomly that seem to make no sense and
the pandemic treaty too I feel like
we're talking about all this with the
variable being the Biden regime right
but I think the climate lockdowns are
something that would probably be
instituted I would argue more from a
Global Perspective I think they would
probably emanate more so out of the
United Nations and if you really look at
the Genesis the origins of the concept
of climate lockdowns and combating
climate change through mandates and
stuff like that it really it's not
really a Biden regime idea it's more of
a United Nations idea I want to say one
thing before we go to the next story I'm
just imagining that there are some like
deep State intelligence agency guys who
have to watch the show every night and
they just saw Ian snap and now they're
all scared like have we gone too far
dude yes you have gone too far it's not
you personally things have gone too far
it's time to reel it in a lot of times
it'll feel like I feel right now you
Ian's like the barometer for like weird
middle of the road dude in this country
who typically doesn't pay attention and
now he's getting angry and they're like
I think we've pushed People Too Far
Let's uh let's jump to the story though
I Love This from NBC News how climate
lockdowns became the new Battleground
for conspiracy driven protest movement
protesters radicalized by their
opposition to coveted lockdowns have a
new Target
anti-traffic measures so they're already
downplaying what the media themselves
were saying years over the past several
years there was an article in the New
York Times that said the cope because of
the coveted lockdowns the Earth was
healing yes like that was something that
I meant to bring up is like the fact
that like in the beginning of the
coveted lockdown it's like all of the
people that are worried about the
environment were just like ooh you know
rubbing their hands together like this
is our shot if we can get people to lock
down we can save the Earth and I I feel
like
they might have gotten the idea to lock
down and and now actually I'm not going
to say that because they probably had it
long before so that's a bad idea but you
think that the two were connected the
climate and the covid opportunity to
lock people down no I I think that the
the idea for a climate log I was going
to say that or pontificate that the idea
for a climate lockdown might have got
started because of covet but then I
thought about it and they probably had
these plans uh started previous to that
so that's why I didn't want to say it
but yeah I think you know slowing the
rate of carbon dioxide production is
okay but if it's gonna destroy or hinder
Humanity I think that's the wrong tactic
because we can reuse the carbon dioxide
particularly to turn it into graphene
and other materials reuse the methane
also and turn it into carbon dioxide my
problem with those kind of like global
scale
um plans that people have if they mess
up you know you're looking at a a death
toll in the billions you mean if they
met if they take too much carbon out of
the air they can kill all the trees and
murder Humanity well I mean I don't I
don't know for sure but like you know
Bill Gates plan to blot out the Sun that
is an actual legit plan that Bill Gates
has been talking like I don't know if
they're talking about uh using something
to seed the clouds and make more clouds
are actually putting some kind of filter
up there to block it he's talked about
it and he's serious I think that's a
terrible idea blocking the amount of sun
that falls on the Earth
seems like it only has a bajillion and a
half ways that it can go wrong and kill
people because that's the only way to
beat the robots man yeah right yeah you
gotta get a black in the sky bro we
don't know if it was us for the robots
also plant life uh relies heavily on
sunlight yeah I also think it's
interesting because so many of these
agendas whether it's the world economic
Forum or the United Nations for some
reason they all have seemed to identify
the year 2030 as like their end goal
right 2013 or 2030 and even the weft has
their own sort of like iteration of it
that also concludes in 2030 China has
their 2030 plan too they also have a
2025 one but I think it'll be really
interesting and that's why I think this
election really is so pivotal because I
think the world not just America will
take two very different trajectories
right if you have someone like Donald
Trump in office I would argue that
agenda 2030 is not going to just get you
know carte blanche blank sign off by
Donald Trump to enforce it whereas if
you have someone like Joe Biden who
empirically throughout you know the
United Nations and the who pandemic
treaty his actions have shown that he's
sort of on board with that and a lot of
his advisors are too I think you will
see two very very different outcomes for
the world writ large depending on who
wins this this election site timing I
really think that even if like someone
and I don't really have a I don't really
care if it's Donald Trump or someone
else but if it is Donald Trump like I
don't think that it's like a guarantee
that he can navigate us through the you
know the coming tumultuous situation of
you know the wef trying to take over the
world I think that Donald Trump is just
a maybe if we go to the Democrat it's a
definite that we're going to do whatever
it is that the International Community
wants we lose our sovereignty if we if
we elect a Democrat because they don't
in they don't push back against the
International Community so whatever the
International Community wants is what
the what the United States does
regardless of what the American people
want let me let me pull this up from
Wikipedia just so you understand agenda
2030. this is from Wikipedia sustainable
development goals from the UN
they say it's uh their Global goals or
sustainable development goals are a
collection of 17 interlinked objectives
designed to serve as a shared blueprint
for peace and prosperity 17 is a magic
number dreaming James Lindsay says too
oh yeah for people and the planet now
into the future they say it was
formulated in 2015 by the UN General
Assembly as part of the post 2015
development agenda they say they were
formally articulated and adopted in a
unga resolution called the 2030 agenda
known colloquially as agenda 2030. so
when you hear people saying this you're
going to get the media saying it's one
big conspiracy theory it's all nonsense
and what they're going to do is they're
going to ignore the actual complaints
people have about the the mission of the
UN and they'll hyper focus on some
random crackpot in an alley who's
screaming that agenda 2030 is trying to
steal moon cheese and they'll be like
these crazy conspiracy theorists think
the Earth is flat and then the average
person who's like hey this is a bit
alarming to me because we're a Sovereign
Nation that shouldn't be giving over our
rights to an international body they
will omit that from the news reports
that's the same same type of thing that
they did with the whole like Jeffrey
Epstein stuff and then the pizza place
like they've they've used the crazy guy
going to the pizza place to to deflect
from like Epstein actually getting
arrested and going and and the trial at
you know and him actually being found
guilty of of human trafficking and stuff
they were using the pizza gate stuff to
discredit the idea that there were
actually right you know and everyone
knows that Epstein had been you know
found guilty of of uh trafficking that
gives Lane
found yeah he got some deal but early on
yeah but uh but everyone knows that that
was the situation they everyone knows
that there have been no names released
and yet people still will say things
like oh Pizza gate you know you're
thinking that it's kind of crazy to
think that there are people in the
government that are pedophiles there's
multiple court cases that have been
found that these people did wasn't like
prince Andrew directly implicated prince
Andrew couldn't wear certain clothing at
the funeral of the queen because of his
embarrassing the royal family like he
couldn't wear his official Cape or
something like that I think it was
military dress I'm not sure what the
what it was but there was official stuff
that that uh that the prince should have
been able to wear ceremonial yeah
disgrace them look at this goal number
one is no poverty
how that's not possible yeah good luck
poverty is relative a poor person today
has better Dental Care than Rockefeller
did 100 years ago 100 and some odd years
ago so that's like it's an impossible
thing to say zero hunger Let's uh hold
on hold on let me let me tell you I'm
supposed to be hungry sometimes I know
my Hunger is a good thing it tells you
that you need to put food in yourself
right uh let's I'm going to approach
this from the view of Ultron the Rogue
AI that was trying to wipe out Humanity
how do you end poverty they say goal
number one is to end poverty in all its
forms everywhere
it would end poverty globally one of its
indicators is the proportion of
population living before the below the
poverty line now you see these these
these lefties and these corporate
journalists or whatever might see that
and say oh I get it if they give all the
poor people more access and money
they'll be above the poverty line and
then all of the international Elites
look at each other like uh sure and what
they're actually envisioning is the
poverty line is the cutoff point where
they excise that portion of the
population and then there's no poor
people anymore then they say zero hunger
same thing how do you get rid of hunger
anyone who's hungry gotta go you know
what I'm saying good health and
well-being anyone who's not gotta go
quality education once again those who
are not getting quality education you
gotta go and we yeah where are you going
anyone that says that about getting rid
of people that are in good health look
at what Canada is doing now with made
like when you first when you first hear
it you think oh it would never happen
but if you think real quick oh wait a
minute it's literally happening in
Canada they were they're encouraging
people people that are a burden to the
system to kill themselves this is not
far-fetched this is not imaginary this
is exactly what a lot of the ngos want
to see happen the the idea that Nations
should end and we should be a global
community in a global country or
whatever you want I got to be honest
like if you were to look through this
population reduction does seem to be a
general path towards acquire
accomplishing a lot of these goals
absolutely think about this how do you
get rid of poverty well if we have
mechanization and Automation and you
remove a large portion of the population
through mate or whatever or through even
even if growth degrowth like this is the
thing people don't understand about this
they assume and the media would want you
to assume that the conspiracy there's a
conspiracy theory where the global leads
are going to go around killing people
it's like okay well maybe with medical
assistance and dying and death or
whatever up in Canada you have something
like that but it's really just like
don't have kids abort your kids
sterilize your kids take birth control
that's degrowth that is one way to
achieve the goal it's um
did you guys ever play we talked about
this before Fallout oh yeah I can't
remember which one it was but the in the
end one of the endings is for those that
aren't familiar it's a post-apocalyptic
World wiped out by nukes there's a
gigantic super intelligent mutant being
who says you can choose to I'll let you
go and you can live but you have to be
sterilized so that you can't reproduce
anymore because you're you're old world
or something that affects us the first
one yeah I think so so the general idea
is no no you're you're mistaken no one
wants to reduce population they just
don't want you to have kids and then in
20 30 years population will have been
reduced tell me about degrowth d-growth
is is essentially
so the way that the the argument goes is
our capitalist Society depends on
infinite growth right it has to keep
growing because we keep having more
people we have to keep producing and we
live on a finite Earth we live on earth
with a a cert with a limited amount of
resources and we are going to use them
up so what we need to do is not we have
to have a net zero impact on the
environment so that means we don't have
an impact Net Zero means a totally zero
impact on the environment and you're
going to achieve that through degrowth
which means you have to have a
contraction of the economies of the
countries on the on the planet
it your GDP is directly related to your
life expectancy every point of GDP that
your country goes down there is a
corresponding number of deaths that
happen so D growth means population
shrinking they and that is intentional
now it starts off and this is and I'm
looking back to the first half of the
20th century Eugenics and population
control and these types of man
controlling Society with big plans like
like they're talking about here these
these type of programs will start off
with one mandate and one one idea and
they and they grow and I hate to do this
because I don't want people to be like
oh you know everyone Compares it but
like the stuff that Hitler did to the
Jews in Nazi Germany didn't start off
with grab them and throw them into the
uh into the concentration camps started
with okay you gotta wear these patches
it starts small so the idea of we have
to do things to contract the government
has to do things to contract they will
start small and as it doesn't work as
fast as they want and as there are
people that will push back they will
continue to up their efforts and you
will end up with I imagine billions debt
I think it's also so it's just so
presumptuous too of the United Nations
to just like assume that those are
shared goals by everyone yeah it's so
euphemistic it's couched
they're not assuming that yeah they
don't care if you want them yeah they
don't care you're in their way yeah but
no that's precisely my point and it
dovetails with what you're saying like
it's not like they're like oh we're
really just you know we're gonna wait we
want to like push these on people when
everyone agrees to it it's like no they
are actively trying to implement this
agenda I think they're doing it very
discreetly now and I think when you look
at how watered down the food supply has
become in terms of how we grow our crops
how devoid they are of nutrients and
minerals the water supply I mean report
after report shows the carcinogenic the
toxic lead and metals heavy metals in
literally every city even like out in
rural areas I really think that that is
is a new form of of biological warfare
that I think they're waging on this
country to make us fat depressed sick
unhappy I mean the levels of magnesium
depletion and amongst so many Americans
which is critical to being happy is so
ridiculous and I think that that's how
they're starting to I want to do a lot
of this I want to jump to the store from
the post-millennial
Donald Trump will be arrested by Fanny
Willis on Thursday in Atlanta he says
I'll be going to Atlanta Georgia on
Thursday to be arrested by a radical
left district attorney
and in the context of all of this uh uh
agenda 2030 type stuff more so how
Democratic politicians agree with
climate lockdown ideas and want to stop
climate change those kinds of things
the view the future I Envision with an
unobstructed Donald Trump is secure
borders
you having a job somewhere factories
coming back and uh kind of the older way
of doing things
what Democrats want and I mean it's
literally I'm not going to use any
euphemisms or conspiracies like
literally when they talk about climate
change they want a reduction in fossil
fuels they don't want factories they
want to Outsource they want you to I
don't know I don't want to say oh
nothing and be happy because that's more
World economic forum but they very much
want you to live in your cubicle box and
just be told what to do and do what you
want and many of the people in cities
seem to be completely okay with it
Donald Trump is an inversion of that and
for that he is their biggest threat
so of course Trump will be arrested but
we do have more news on this a second
Georgia lawmaker is seeking the
impeachment of Rogue district attorney
Fanny Willis so with everything we've
talked about so far in terms of degrowth
and agenda 2030 climate lockdowns
coveted lockdowns may be coming back it
is not a foregone conclusion there is a
very clear path to Victory and I think
it is the obvious path to Victor and I
think it is the likely path to Victory I
think it is a likely outcome Donald
Trump only lost in 2020 by a margin of
about 42 000 votes in three states
there's I I think it is unlikely they
screw it up this time
Trump has already said we need a bad
harvesting operation
they're already already being moves made
there's more activism ramping up and the
Democrats don't have the advantage of
hard lockdowns you need a hundred Scott
presslars is what they need and they
have to get rid of they need to get rid
of McDonald's that's one thing that I
wanted to ask you what is your take on
Ronald McDaniel
put me on the spot I know well I like to
call her Ronda Romney McDaniel don't
forget that because so okay that's all I
need to know honestly you've just
literally given me here you buried the
lead no I think the RNC loves to
fundraise a bunch of money off of
well-meaning Patriots use it to use
really really cushy uh you know Retreats
at five star resorts and do absolutely
nothing and I think they spit in the
face and they're laughing behind the
backs of people like Scott Pressler
um people who are actually doing the
work and I don't think anyone should
give any money to the RNC and look no
further than the Antics they've been up
to with this whole debate that's
happening tomorrow trying to get Trump
to join in on it Rana is a is a joke she
spends I think a lot of the money on lip
fillers
why do you feel like Trump got behind
her
or what it what do you think he was
thinking because I think that was
probably one of the worst things that he
did since he's been out of office is
actually putting his support behind Ron
McDaniel she's the in my opinion she's
the biggest person at fault for allowing
the Democrats to just outperform them to
out politic them you know it's like on
the the ground game that the Republicans
had was such an embarrassment compared
to the Democrats and the Democrats run
rings around them and it's Ron
McDaniel's fault she was in charge so
like where's the accountability you know
and what are they actually doing to make
sure that it doesn't happen again
because if you re like I really do think
that the biggest culprit for why Donald
Trump didn't didn't isn't in the in the
white house now is Ron McDaniels in the
RNC I think it's twofold I think in
addition to the RNC just being like the
abysmal little sister of the DNC
couldn't even compete if they if they
wanted to I also think the DNC has sort
of an extension of an app that is the
groups like the center for Tech and
Civic life right the Zuckerberg type
groups and we just because we are the
right we don't have that and I would
argue that independent of the DNC I
think those so-called non-profits that
really shady dark money apparatus
is what allowed Democrats to win more so
I I I'm you're not Ronan I'm not trying
to put you on the spot so but why do you
think it is that like I'm definitely not
wrong I know so I'm not trying I'm not
trying to put you on the spot but like
so then why do you think it is that like
nothing was done like why is it that
that she
like because because the things
Democrats have have a history of having
a better ground game and because of the
fact that they tend to Cluster in urban
areas it's easier for them to do things
like get you know ballot Harvest why is
it that Rona hasn't you know nobody has
thought about the fact that that this is
you know this is the way things are like
why didn't why weren't they prepared I
you know I don't I don't know no I I
think you know it's the same question
and the same answer and the same logical
just anger that you get when you ask why
House Republicans aren't doing anything
anything really meaningful when it comes
to the hunter Biden investigation to
impeaching Joe Biden to these coveted
mandates to defunding the government and
I think the issue is it's exactly and
precisely people like Rana who really to
their their Court yeah maybe they're
Republican but they're not really
conservative again I was going to say
Trump supporters Maga type but I know
that for some people that might not
necessarily be what they identify with
but I think these are people who are
very okay with the staff status quo
because the status quo means that they
retain their power and I don't really
think Rana cares if Republicans lose
elections I don't really I just think
she wants to retain her position Phil
would anybody go watch the Harlem
Globetrotters if the Washington generals
won
they'd be I would buy tickets to the
next game
it would be interesting yeah to be
completely honest but uh I I I just I
hate to break this to you Phil but the
generals they're meant to lose I mean I
you know I I wish I wish that we had a
legitimate opposition party how about
that it looked like we were turning
point USA Charlie Kirk I think they were
who was it Harvey Dylan running against
Army was gr I thought don't forget no oh
they both work yes the energy in the
room was electrifying at the turning
point when we were talking about it Army
was there and I thought like of course
it's like confirmation bias I was like
she's definitely gonna win with this
kind of support it was only like a
thousand people you know and of course
you get caught up in your own smell but
like uh then I I mean that's the that's
the Lively Republican basis Charlie Kirk
and turning point like that's young
people yeah yeah so I just don't know
why I mean I don't know if there's
malfeasance behind the scenes and that's
why Rhonda took it if Ron is just more
popular on the global stage so that's
why she got it did they vote well I also
think the RNC election rate's not
actually Americans voting it's people
within the confines of the RNC and I
think what you're talking about right
the disconnection or rather just
connects between the Grassroots
activists actual Maga type people and
the selection of Rana and it's sort of
like the same phenomenon phenomenon I
would argue with Trump in 2016 or that
was the first time there was a candidate
who actually appealed to the actual
Republican voting base as opposed to the
more Elite you know donor class and I
think unfortunately the RNC I mean
there's a reason it has the reputation
it does for the most part and there are
some RNC members who are you know more
populous who are you know come on war
room all the time and are always willing
and down to slam Rana but I think
unfortunately most of the members of the
RNC because think about how you get to
be in the RNC you don't go get to be a
member of the RNC or the committee
Mentor committee woman if you're like a
hardcore outspoken populist type you
know doing hardcore Trump activism they
were against Trump in 2016. so I think
you have a lot of holdovers there who
again not that it's about Trump as a
person it's about more than that it's
about the Strand the stripe of the
Republican party and the voters who who
get behind him and I think the Rana
Romney McDaniels of the world the elite
Republican the country club Republican
class has done everything in their power
to suppress and quash that stripe of
conservatism
oh well that makes sense
you know Vivek I was listening to him
ramaswamy on Sean Ryan's podcast last
night and he was saying I like it's
really not about Republicans versus
Democrats it's about the I guess you
would call it the administrative class
versus everybody else and they've got
this stupid lock and he's like just you
gotta fire them you've gotta cancel the
FBI and musician a lot of the the people
in other departments and things we
should not have a political class
I agree it's weird to me that there's a
political class that should not exist
people who are born and bred and
educated for the sole purpose of being
in charge of people makes no sense right
I'm sorry that's how it maybe used to be
with Lords and stuff like that but now
this is supposed to be a country for
oven by the people which means it's
supposed to be a person who is running
for office here's why here's my
experience instead
perhaps only because of the natural uh
Tendencies of man people who Carpenters
plumbers electricians taxi drivers you
name it astronauts it's like look I
don't want to deal with these policies
can we just get someone else to do it
and that's how it happened in the
federal government it came from laziness
according to Vivek when he was on our
show He was discussing this about a
month ago that the people in Congress
just didn't want to do the work anymore
so they outsourced it to the uh what do
you call it the Federal Reserve yeah
they like they create these external
things to do their work that they should
be doing that's because if they take
votes and they're if they vote on the
record they have to answer to their
constituents if they pass the buck to
someone else I didn't do it so when they
go back to win Congress people go back
to their their uh their areas
um you know they can be like oh well you
know I tried and I told you I wouldn't
I've tried to but you know it didn't
work so because this is how it goes now
it's all about getting the the less
they're responsible for the happier they
are because it's more likely they'll win
their the re they'll win re-election so
taking responsibility for the actions is
a huge part of why they Outsource it or
why they've been trying to that's why
they did it with with Donald Trump with
the uh or not I'm sorry not Donald Trump
with uh George Bush when he came to the
Iraq War and stuff they gave him the
authorization for use of force they're
supposed to declare war they didn't
actually that's what makes the Iraq War
illegal is the Congress doesn't have the
authority to give the president the
authority to make war the president can
react so the president can send the
Marine Corps to like you know to save
American lives or whatever but the
president can't conduct War the Congress
is supposed to is supposed to declare
war if we go to war when Congress gave
the president that power they didn't
have the power to do that so that means
that the president didn't have the power
because Congress didn't have the power
to give the president the power so when
the president ordered all the troops
into Iraq it was illegal because he
didn't have the legal Authority the uh
the authorization for the use the force
is an unconstitutional document it was
an unconstitutional law so is the
Federal Reserve Act also
unconstitutional legal the Federal
Reserve Act is unconstitutional there
was an amendment that I believe was was
uh improperly
um
improperly ratified that was for the the
Federal Reserve but the Federal Reserve
there there are people that will make
the argument that it is unconstitutional
because it is not outlined in the in the
Constitution
um but there are also people that are
going to say that the necessary and
proper clause uh allows for it let's
jump to this story from timcast.com
ladies and gentlemen Trump pack creates
2024 vice presidential debate website
trolling Fox News and other candidates
that's right Trump has announced he will
not attend the debate Wednesday and
apparently he said debates he's not
gonna do any of them which airs on Fox
News instead he will sit with the
Network's ousted former host Tucker
Carlson for a one-on-one interview
that's going to be really interesting
that'll be big
well here's the website VP debate what
is this the only person here is Chris
Christie oh okay when you format the web
when you shrink the website mobile yeah
it's like there we go there we go let's
uh let's zoom out a little bit and uh
battle for the vice presidency look
vivek's got 55 can I I can't scroll down
here can I I just gotta make it small
it's better for second place yeah look
at that
for the 2024 vice presidential debate
and Vivek ramaswami's got 55 actually
really really like this yeah uh I'm not
gonna watch a debate I don't care about
the the GOP debate I would be surprised
if many of you intend to watch it oh
this is gonna be that's not you we got
to watch this we can't oh that sucks Fox
News has explicitly stated they will
take anyone down who rebroadcasts any
portion of the show Beyond a small
amount a small snippet uh if we do it
after it airs is that okay what a
ridiculous dude it's democracy this is
the American Republic you're supposed to
proliferate the data there is an
argument that is it is a newsworthy
event they cannot make that move but Fox
News wants to play dirty and assert that
they will go after anyone who
rebroadcast the debate and they don't
have Donald Trump it was a really easy
decision for me to be like oh well I
don't care yeah that's too bad because
this is going to be way more interesting
than some crusty old dude sitting out
with Tucker Carlson
Trump and Tucker is going to be crazy
yeah this debate
Haley Hutchins a constitutionalist he
understands the Constitution and laws
and he's going to school everyone on
stage about it sure I'll watch the clips
after the fact but I don't I don't see I
I really don't look man I gotta be
honest if it was just Rhonda Sanderson
ramaswami I'd be like there's always
this will be interesting but I don't
care about Nikki Haley come on Mike
Pence and Nikki Haley and go back and
forth is a waste of my time yeah I would
be tuning into this for Vivek yeah but
they're not and he'll probably get more
speaking time because he's going to be
assertive but that still doesn't matter
they're they're is this are they
seriously gonna have Chris Christie
debating Nikki Haley
if you did Tim Scott Rhonda Sanderson
and Rama Swami I bet this will be
interesting but the rest of them just
make it not worth watching
this is a lot like remember just 2008
debates the Democratic debates where
like Mike Gravel was on the enemy like
you bunch of War Hawks even especially
you Joe and you Hillary like he's
calling
us so good it was like 12 of them and
they only got like three minutes each
you know except for Hillary and Barack
and and they gave Biden some time too so
they'll probably do something similar
with this although I don't know I mean
this is like Trump's version of of it at
first I was like oh screw Donald Trump
mocking these people and now I see he's
put Vivek this is basically Trump's way
of saying Vivek is the number two guy in
the Republican party right now all right
so so uh put a put a two in chat if you
think this debate is going to be worth
your time and uh put a nine in chat if
you would rather watch Donald Trump and
Tucker Carlson here's my issue and I
mentioned this before the show and I'd
like to I'll reiterate it for you guys
and people listening is that I was
listening to that Sean Ryan interview
with vague last night Vivek was saying
how you know when When Donald Trump was
in office and he wanted to end the
administrative state that you want to
drain the swamp he didn't know how so he
asked his advisors how do I do it and
they said you can't you don't have the
authority because of the uh because of
the um civil Protection Services Civil
Service protections act you can't fire
people in the administrative States so
Trump was like okay
Alaska when Vivid looked into it he was
like oh okay well they told me I can't
I'm gonna go read the law myself I'm
going to read the Constitution myself
which is something Donald Trump has
never done so Vivek read it he realized
oh I can legally do it those guys were
lying to Donald Trump because they are
deep State and you can go in and re
reorganize and reformat the actual
organizations themselves the FBI
themselves you can gut you can just
terminate the FBI
you can't fire the individuals but you
can terminate the service and then re
reposition or lay off the individuals
and that's like Donald Trump doesn't
read I'm not saying he never reads but
he doesn't he's known for it it was
almost like yeah
this is why I Tucker Carlson and Trump's
gonna be so interesting because Trump
gets his opinions from Tucker Carlson
and from the deep State apparently so I
don't want a guy a lot of advisor it's
going to be hilarious but no no no like
come on man 90 plus percent of Trump's
opinions come from watching Tucker
that's what he was famous for he would
tweet something at like two in the
morning and you'd be like yup he clearly
just watched that Tucker Carlson segment
so now he's gonna be sitting down with
Tucker and it's going to be real
interesting and I want to add everybody
is putting nine in chat
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly agree that
the vice presidential debate will be a
waste of time because there's no reason
to listen to Nikki Haley argue with Mike
Pence it's it's true and also like you
know I mean Trump and Tucker are like
the two most popular and most
influential names in in the conservative
what is the side of the aisle what if
the real reason they're doing it is that
Trump is going to announce Tucker
Carlson as his VP that's what Vivek
thought Tucker would be a good VP what
if tomorrow it's like this is not
actually an interview it's a discussion
about our potential platform I'm
announcing Tucker Carlson as my vice
presidential pick that would be kind of
hilarious dunk
yeah I mean I mean it's not going to
happen but I I wish my big problem real
quick sorry no no we we always talk
about how great this timeline is when
silly things happen yeah but if we
really weren't the greatest of timelines
it would be Trump announcing in that sit
down that they're running together
anymore I don't get it I don't I he
wasn't the worst guy on Earth at all but
like he doesn't read the Constitution
why would you want that guy in charge of
your military
no one else does he Barack Obama was a
constitution he was a lawyer like a
litigator he understood the Constitution
inside and out and so does Vivek like
the only reason that Barack Obama knew
anything about the Constitution is so he
could make laws to get around well he
looked at the Constitution as an in as
an in well he looked the Constitution as
a bad thing because of what it does
which is inhibit the federal government
Barack Obama as a constitutional lawyer
is not a good thing it was so that way
he could defeat the Constitution he was
not a friend of Liberty or a friend of
limited government or a friend of the
Constitution his knowledge of the
Constitution was exclusively so that way
he could circumvent the limits put on
the government by the Constitution well
I think he learned about it before he
became president and then once he got in
there he definitely got co-opted by the
Deep State well I mean yes he did but
this so this is this is this goes to two
different ways to look at the
Constitution right so the conservatives
look at the Constitution they call it a
dead document right it doesn't change
you look at it that's what it says
that's what it means Barack Obama and
progressives believe that it is a living
document actually I think they're liars
and just making an excuse of that way
they can get around the limiting factors
in the Constitution but they say that
it's a living document what that means
is you take what it says and you think
about today and you think well what is
going to be best for today and now and
then you say well that's what it means
which is a friggin lie and the reason
you know it's a lie is because if the
founders really wanted the Constitution
to be interpreted they wouldn't have put
an extremely difficult and stringent
method of changing the Constitution in
the friggin Constitution I wanna I wanna
add this too I can't speak for every
Trump supporter some people genuinely
think he's the best ever I just think
he's a rampaging bull that he's like
just an angry bull and he's going to
romp about and just wreak havoc in the
bureaucratic state but then they're like
but hold on hold on now now that sounds
pretty good to a lot of people the bowl
bucks and then kicks the door open and
they're all going like oh Jesus like the
Bulls rampaging around and jumping on
the sofa and they're freaking out now
imagine Vivek ramaswamy is rodeoing with
that bull riding on the back of it and
he rides in using that ball to bring in
some effective policy yeah that's why
I'm like I don't know if a vape would be
VP but that'd be fantastic even Tucker
that the the original selling point of
Ron DeSantis was as everyone was like
he'd be the he's the VP he's the guy
because he's younger tactful and
perceived and more procedural he's he's
a little bit more dry a bit more boring
but that makes him a better VP makes him
one of the best VPS and then he decided
he was the big dog and was going to run
a campaign into the ground and now he's
just like not out of the picture Vivek
ran the campaign DeSantis should have
run and now Vivek is in the prime
position according to this vice
presidential debate 55 of people are
like Vivek man I I think a trump Rama
Swami ticket would be absolutely
incredible I like the bull metaphor I do
of Donald Trump because he's in there he
doesn't know which direction to turn
next he's just smashing what he thinks
he's supposed to smash and vivek's like
a wizard with laser eyes that has
surgical Precision where he goes in
evaporates areas of of walls and
structures that need to be evaporated
while leaving the rest he knows what
he's doing can can someone draw a
picture of like Vivek as a wizard with a
wizard staff and an angry bull with
Trump's hair storming into like
government you know yeah you know that
would be the greatest comic someone make
that on AI the ball is just rampaging
around as the Deep State bureaucrats are
running in panic and then Vivek is
making hovering violent cabinets
disappear yeah it's his surgical
Precision that I appreciate the whole
like burn it all down mentality is just
it got people fired up in 2016 it
angered so many people with its
vagueness and uh and then you get a guy
that comes in there who's specific about
how he's going to dismantle the Deep
State I see no other path than the
specific dismantling here's the other
thing too why isn't uh because someone's
that one gamer just super chatted Larry
Elder is not on the debate stage he is
substantially more relevant than say
like
I don't know he's a Hutchinson I don't
even know who this guy is bargain
he was
just a breakfast club with Doug he's
he's polling well enough to be here but
Larry Elder isn't that's wild yeah I
like Larry Eller his first I know that's
fantastic his like first words wrote
Donald Trump too
his first words were about that yeah
yeah oh like he's complaining about
Donald Trump no we're thankful for
president Trump but his first words are
about Donald Trump like he's still in
the comments people are gonna are gonna
Lackey for Trump how many people how
many of these people what are there
eight of them how many of them do you
think are gonna mention Donald Trump's
name is this this website is praising
Trump they're they're taking quotes from
these people praising Trump on purpose
it's not hard for Vivek I think that's
funny they got what Ron Rhonda says I
think Donald Trump has done a better job
appointing judges to both the U.S
Supreme Court and appeals court that end
to the president my lifetime including
one of my heroes Ronald Reagan yikes I
man this it's a special kind of ego to
make a website like this it was made by
a pack not by train oh okay yeah right
people who support Trump made this but
to be fair whatever kind of ego you're
gonna go ahead and talk about Donald
Trump has it it's just so disgusting
like he I mean this is intimating that
these people are beneath him it's
disgusting that's exactly no they're not
Vivek is what trounce
yeah Vivek I would say is he's a younger
guy but uh he's he's he's on Trump's
level in a lot of respects I think in
terms of the
uh the the I like
Vivek is not
I don't describe this Trump has that
Chieftain kind of like like pounding on
his chest you know Hulk smash kind of an
80s bravado with with Trump yeah yeah
but that doesn't have that no but fake
has other other powerful qualities that
I like yeah like being smart
yes like he's he's tactful he's
procedural he's he's surgical as Ian
pointed out he is in many ways a
balancing Force for Trump in the way
that we thought Ron would be he's just
not as hilarious As Trump he's funny but
he's not as hilarious Trump the shirt
off playing tennis was funny oh yeah I
laughed
so funny
I don't know but it was hilarious just
him like I want to know if he was
playing with that that motherfucker's
not real who's he playing that whip but
the funny thing about that clip is it
didn't show the actual game yeah it was
just a clip of a vet going
on lightning speed slam I love it was it
his wife was he playing with no I don't
know who advised him to make that video
but I appreciate it thank you I'm
starting to see if evix wife get
involved uh is apurva is how you
pronounce her name she's a doctor uh
operating operating doctor I'm not sure
exactly but I thought you were the
in-house Vivek expert and vivec fan you
should you should know that I'm a huge
huge fan of the intelligence and in fact
I don't even like him I like like what
he's doing I appreciate how he is
working the system he's just reminds me
of like my high school friends kind of
like Middle America Ohio he's an Ohio
guy reminds me a lot of my buddy Ted
cortler class president like go get him
go get him V like I knew you always knew
you'd be president man I think with the
exception maybe of vivec just because I
know a lot of his campaign is to some
extent self-funded or just let's see
right
um I I do think that the other people
who are on that stage I know you said oh
Donald Trump thinks they're beneath him
I honestly do think that those people
are beneath Donald Trump and this is why
I say that because those people who are
running have absolutely no chance of
winning and it is all just an exercise I
think to divert a lot of money that
could be put towards much better
securing the ballot securing your vote
initiatives for Republican candidates
and I think the worst part when it comes
to people like Ron DeSantis the Tim
Scotts of the world that is just one
grift operation for the consultant class
that I think runs a lot of the
Republican party and if you want to get
into really what the issue with the RNC
isn't more broadly the Republican party
it's the entrenchment of these
Consultants who have absolutely no idea
what Grassroots or activists are into
and or care about whether they don't
know or they just pretend not to care
and all of those people who are running
it's just an operation to make those
people a bunch of money I think that
critique lands particularly well with
the DeSantis campaign but like I said
you have someone like Donald Trump who
the administrative state is waging I
would argue full-blown Warfare you're
talking four indictments you name it
against him and to see these people
adding on to the charge against him I'm
not saying that you know someone can't
be challenged that Donald Trump is a
king but I think in the historical
context and the level and gravity to
which the Deep state is assaulting him
right now for these people to be piling
on against him and having us divert our
resources away from really securing the
general election I think that does mean
that those people are beneath him I
agree but let's jump to another story
about someone who's absolutely beneath
Donald Trump and that is Joe Biden in
this story from the post millennial they
say Joe Biden appears to fall asleep
during meeting with Maui survivors now I
know I know all of these news out
they're trying to be very careful over
litigation they don't want to say that
Joe Biden did fall asleep despite the
fact that on video he appears to fall
asleep and they say appears to fall
asleep I am just going to say this upon
review of this video which I'll play for
you here Joe Biden is falling asleep
I mean I think it's fair to say he
appears to be falling to have fallen
asleep
I am going to say I believe Joe Biden
fell asleep
yeah Charlie Kirk says octogenarian Joe
Biden seems to be falling asleep while
meeting with survivors of the Maui fires
fires yup he just like pops up look at
this he's like oh oh look at this is
funny his eyes slowly open he's like
wait he might have died for a second
wow he definitely just woke up there
yeah he's sleeping okay I I think it's
fair to say he appears to be sleeping
because he did we want to be precise
when you sleep you do appear to be
sleeping I'm gonna say outright yo that
guy's asleep yeah when you're asleep you
do appear to be sleeping I know he fell
asleep I'm not mad at Joe Biden for
falling asleep
I am not mad at Joe Biden for falling
asleep I am met the people who voted for
him yeah
um 80 year old man so everyone
understand you're like okay Grandpa come
on ice cream fine I'll get you ice cream
then he takes a crap in his pants and
everyone's got to smell it and it's like
dude I'm not mad at the old man who's
trying to live his life and wants to
live his best life I met the people who
enabled someone who was incapable uh
better yet not to poop to poop the pants
thing let's say 80 year old guy with
really bad videos I want to drive the
car and you're like no grandpa the 67
Corvette you should not be driving
you're gonna drive okay fine you can
drive any crashes it I was like okay
come on man at a certain point loved
ones need to be alike Joe come on he's
the cash cow if you're rich Grandpa it's
like I'm gonna drive and you know he's
not healthy for it but he's like he's
the one that's giving you your monthly
allowance so you're like we have no
choice if we don't let him drive he cuts
us off dude wow he's a big guy dude it's
amazing just just let him be president
he's paying them even if even if the
pedestrians are at risk just let him
drive yeah they're like if he's the
president our checks are gonna get so
much bigger than when he was a vice
president yep triple quadruple yeah so I
saw this story I saw the video of
everyone flicking him off in Hawaii it's
crazy they're all screaming F you at him
as he drives through because 700 ain't
doing nothing some guy was holding up a
sign saying the people of Ukraine Got
1700 if you break down how much money
was sent to Ukraine for the war and the
people of Lahaina only got 700. yeah Joe
Biden is a is a is a corporeal body that
Democrats needed to go up against Trump
that's all he is and so of course he's
falling asleep people voted for this
they were like I'd rather have this than
Donald Trump throwing paper towels to
people are you kidding I'd rather have
Trump they're throwing paper towels to
people at least paper towels you can dry
stuff you can wipe your hands with Joe
Biden's sleeping is is nothing it's
negative it's it's it's it's it's chaos
yeah it's a it's a puppetry he's that's
and I think that's a lot of what this
administrative class wants is puppets I
think Vivek was talking I keep bringing
them up but they were talking about Sean
Ryan great great Episode by the way Sean
Ryan spectacular interviewer about how
John fetterman like what the hell they
put a guy with brain damage from a
recent stroke in to Congress but did you
see the picture of him because they need
a puppet but with not only that but the
thing is he's in you he's kind of immune
from criticism if you put like so if you
attack John fetterman then they're going
to go ahead and say well you're you're
attacking someone that's that's disabled
it's ableism for attacking him and it's
like wait a minute
is it too close no oh the mustache yeah
I honestly think that's a better look
it's about oh yeah you know I probably
would like the guy if I knew him
one-on-one but man why would you put
someone like that in Congress I'd
probably like him if I was able to
actually communicate with him and
understand where he came from but I
think that time has long since passed
I'm not saying to be mean I'm saying the
dude can't communicate anymore like you
watch these videos and the Democrats are
clapping for things that are incoherent
yeah like I mean it doesn't the
Democrats the person doesn't matter
whether it's Dianne Feinstein who who
just had her her Handler tell her just
say yay because she started talking
about something that was a non-sequitur
or something uh whether it's this guy
whether it's Kamala Harris who can
barely complete a sentence
McConnell had like a brain fart stroke
no one knows in the middle of giving a
speech yeah it's fair not fair there are
old people on both sides um so fair
enough yeah Mitch McConnell he should
get out of the turtle
um but the point I think the point that
I'm making though is is the left does
doesn't really have a whole lot of you
know differing opinions on it it's
they're all very in lockstep so it
doesn't matter who the person is yeah
because look at Dianne Feinstein yeah
exactly you know she was her daughter as
power of attorney yeah and she it was
really funny she was gone for what three
months her daughter has power of
attorney and for some reason she's
allowed to stay in her in her seat her
that means that she her daughter has to
make all of her choices for her all of
her her daughter has the position yeah
her daughter is her daughter technically
is probably the uh unelected uh yeah
for sure is but Feinstein was out for
what was like three months was it and
then she was like I've been here the
whole time yeah it's like it's right and
the fact that we and we allow the
hospital we allow this I just don't know
how to do it peacefully legally to
remove the old people and put like fresh
intelligent young people in you don't
room you don't have the ability to
remove or to to affect Dianne Feinstein
because you know
well possibly but you're not her
constituent you know what I mean you
couldn't do anything about her the only
thing we can do is is we could get some
kind of Constitutional Amendment that
says you have either a age limit or
there's some kind of test or you know
cognitive test or whatever
um but because of the way that our
government is is set up you don't have
the ability to do anything about
fetterman in Pennsylvania because you're
not as constituent you know I mean so
you writing to his you know office like
being like yo you should resign to be
like well who's this clown from Maryland
you know they or whatever they wouldn't
care so I also think that in the case of
Joe Biden that the DNC and Democrats
were really drawn to someone who is so
it's going to say out to lunch but I
think that's too nice a term but someone
who is just so not there because when
you contrast him with you know Chieftain
Donald J Trump I think they really hated
Trump in part policies aside because he
was a strong man right in other words a
bull in a china shop you didn't know
what he was going to do but implied in
that is that what he wanted to do he
hadn't agenda he had an idea you
couldn't and I'm sure we would disagree
on this but you couldn't easily
manipulate him to the extent that you
could just get Joe Biden to like do
anything and I would almost argue the
fact that the hunter Biden hard drive
all the compromising business deals in
some way that was like the insurance
policy that they wanted on a candidate
like Joe Biden because they they know
that they could control him and I think
that's why they're so drawn to these
politicians who are just so like
listless vessels I'll use a quote uh I
like that phrase because they're the
opposite right thesis antithesis of
Donald Trump you can't you it's a lot
easier to control someone like that and
I have to say just to juxtapose what
went on in Maui today and it goes back
to my point about the strong man with
what you see going on at the brick
Summit right now the Brazil Russia India
China South Africa
I mean talk about an abdication of
America from from the world stages you
see all these various deals energy deals
being pursued not in the US dollar but
in Petra dollars and and really the
dollarization of the global economy it's
because of actions like that from Joe
Biden it's the absence of a strong man
an actual figure on the world stage who
has I mean I would say Vision but
actually just has the brain cells to
like create Vision internally that I
think is why you're seeing really
America just fall into utter utter chaos
on the world stage in these other
countries really overstep so it's they
should send Phenom in Hawaii he
um he'd maybe do a better job I he would
I think so that's the point yeah he
would be saying incoherent things but
he'd be awake
what else can I say
yeah it is it is an absurd reality for
this country when the man who can't read
or I'm sorry he can't understand words
being said to him and struggles to speak
would do a better job than the president
who fell asleep
yeah he also Joe Biden went down there
and and in true Joe Biden form started
talking about how he understood what
they were going through because he
experienced something very similar oh my
God his kitchen caught on fire one time
and that was the the I know what you're
going through oh I know that your child
burned alive one time my kitchen caught
on fire and oh my kid died of brain
cancer no wait I I have a cat my cat
almost we almost lost that cat when he
talked to the military I don't I don't I
don't care to rag on these like single
singular statements that Biden makes and
things like this where everyone's like
I I get it he's garbage and I'm just
kind of like yeah yeah yeah you know if
you want you like to be fair you could
pull quotes from every president and be
alike that was a bit tactless my bigger
concern is he fell asleep yeah it's like
his overall condition is really weird
you can you can have you can make a
mistake in a blunder by saying some
stupid story and I can pull up any
president anytime who had a quote that
was that was not so good
but come on the dude can't stay awake
it was Hawaii was he was in Hawaii time
so it's three hours earlier let's be
kind
if you can't do the job don't ask for it
I'm not gonna if someone hundred pound
woman is like I'd like to be a
firefighter I'd be like can you carry a
150 pound person up and down the stairs
I will push I got no beef with women but
I'm like come on this job requires you
to save someone's life don't push the
button to have Joe Biden resign and have
Kamala Harris become president right now
I would love that I gotta be honest I
think kamalair Kamala would be worse
it's it's yes you know what she's gonna
do okay I would rather have a president
sleeping than to have Kamal Harris go
fire
is bad
and I'm here because of Fire
and everyone's gonna be like what that's
the interesting argument would you
rather have a vacant non-president or a
bad president that's like ruthlessly
evil and horrible just check it out I
think she's quite fetterman would would
be there and he would do better than
both of them not by much but he'd be
like yeah the the fire and you people
get hurt
proper grass the the fire and I'm like
well I can see some indignation in his
voice and he asked for people to get
hurt so I'll take that water
on fire you know we understand
yeah yeah Kamala she would say I love
those quotes from her she's like
children are the community because the
community has children and you're like
what I believe why children but I mean
the future my having a president that's
asleep at the wheel is got to be worse
than a psycho I'm not saying kamo is
psycho evil but like it's got to be
worse than having a psycho even wanted
to keep a man a man that was that she
had evidence that she knew that he was
innocent she kept him on death row yes
she is evil do you know what that guy's
name was oh man but I'd rather have evil
and aware and awake and alive and
intelligent than stupidly why do you
want smart evil as opposed to dumb evil
well it's opposed to nothing smart evil
or no president I'd rather have a smart
evil president than no president falling
asleep like where's his relationship
with the Russians where's his
relationship with the Chinese spy
balloon where's his relationship with
the disaster relief from Maui if he's
not doing anything he's not messing
anything up yeah but then there's just
it's it's all incoherence yeah chaos I
mean I don't know what's better
a sane rational I don't know like Marcus
Aurelius type well I mean obviously
Marcus Aurelius is like you know he's
one of the the greatest Cincinnati in
history you know I think because our our
country has such checks and balances
that I feel like an evil president would
get overwritten a lot of times by the
rest of the branches of government no I
disagree I think I mean the kind that
would start a war that killed a million
people in the Middle East yeah the evil
ones get away with it because the evil
ones bribe those beneath them and the
good ones don't
and so the the good President says no no
we can't do that we can't go to war and
they say we gotta remove this guy he's
costing us money the evil one says go to
war and I'll give you a cut and they're
like yes I'd like to see in chat if you
would rather have Kamala Harris type of
one well let's do no Kamal Harris type
of two
Joe Biden type of four
which one do you want as president right
now let's uh let's jump to this next
story they are trying to smear the good
name of Oliver Anthony this guy who
wrote the biggest song in the world rich
men north of Richmond and we got this we
got a couple of tweets there's more than
just these going around because he gave
a statement to Griff I believe it's
Griff Jenkins over on Fox News
let me play the clip for you first that
people are sharing here you go I mean we
are the Melting Pot of the world and
that that's what makes us strong is our
diversity and we need to learn to
harness that and appreciate it and not
use it as a political tool to keep
everyone separate from each other you
know I mean so that's the clip they're
showing and this guy uh nine millimeter
SMG says accent disappeared say the line
diversity makes a strong clap still of
it to find a single person to explain to
me how diversity is a strength explain
to me how a cohesive unit is less
functional anyone looks like he got the
call from the rich men north of Richmond
we then have this one where they said
Oliver Anthony quote We Are The Melting
Pot of the world and that's what makes
us strong our diversity such a letdown
did he sell out already to the rich men
north of Richmond oh they are trying to
smear this regular guy a working-class
guy calling out the fat cats in the
elites with a with an out of context
quote I'm going to show you the full
quote
he said I don't see our country lasting
more than another generation the way we
are headed we have to go back to the
roots of what made this country great in
the first place which was our sense of
community We Are The Melting Pot of the
world and that's what makes us strong is
our diversity we need to learn to
harness that and appreciate it and not
use it as a political tool to keep
everyone separate from each other first
of all if you thought this guy who wrote
this song was going to come out and just
agree with literally everything you said
then you were mistaken more importantly
the dude is saying exactly what we say
all the time one Community is the most
important thing that's why we're doing
this coffee shop that's why we want to
do Saturday morning cartoons we call it
where we bring families together he says
we have to go back to the roots of what
made this country great in the first
place
absolutely we talk about this all the
time
everybody who championed his song
there's no reason for anyone to pretend
that they're outraged over him saying
this we completely agree this is the
antithesis of wokeness woke people are
like the country is inherently evil
since 1619 the slave ocracy has ruled
Supreme and white supremacy must be
destroyed and here's a guy saying no no
we got to go back we got to go back to
what made this country great the idea of
diversity I'll explain it for you
diversity does not mean that you take a
whole bunch of people of different
backgrounds isolate them from each other
and then tell each of them that they're
all their enemy diversity is what the
Melting Pot truly was when you came to
this country you melted into it meaning
you became part of the greater culture
Oliver Anthony is correct I like this
guy me too man diversity for instance
very literally would be like if you have
a bunch of small a bunch of short people
and then they can't get the fruit out of
the tree they die off uh now you have a
group that's a bunch of tall people that
can't get into the hole in the ground to
catch the rabbits so they starve they
all die off now you have some tall
people and some short people the short
people going to the holes the tall
people get the fruit I love this story
diversity is strength completely wrong
but right in so many ways you need to
catch rabbits in the holes
and tall people can still catch rabbits
but your point is 100 skin color like
are not not necessarily the color but
our ancient genetics can make us more or
less resistant to uh sickness like
certain bacteria and viruses so like if
a virus comes through and wipes out a
lot of one ethnicity or one you know
cultural background the others are
spared the species survives listen
that's called hybrid Vigor they there
was this study that I read a while ago
it shows that people who have kids with
people from the further away your
partner is from as a point of origin
from the planet the the better their
their child's immune system may turn out
to be and I'm like that's really really
fascinating that is the American Melting
Pot idea of diversity that two things
come together and become one but more
importantly
what is he saying with communities
Melting Pot that means when a an
immigrant family comes to the United
States they don't create their isolated
little pocket Community where they don't
speak English they integrate they melt
into what America already is and are
underneath our cultural umbrella and
then you get like Chinatown in New York
which is you know Chinese
and it adheres to our rules and our laws
and our Constitution and they end up for
the most part learning English I mean
that's that's why they move to America
is to learn English and become part of
the culture so he's like there's the
people that that are criticizing him it
seems like and this is this is an
assumption but it seems like they're
people that are
expressing that they feel like he's not
right enough like not right-wing enough
like he is a plant uh leftist because
he's saying the quote unquote leftist
buzzwords things like diversity but I
think the guy's just not an extremely
online dude right like we all see you
know the term diversity and there's all
kinds of things attached to it comes
with a ton of baggage because of the way
that the left uses it because of what
the the term diversity means according
to uh Scholars and and the way that it
the the the discrepancy uh in the
definition versus the way that the left
tends to apply it so there's all that
stuff attached to it right but if you're
just a normal guy that goes to work and
you know writes a song the idea of we
should have a diverse country is
something that you especially like his
age that's something that everybody kind
of grew up with the idea that everybody
comes to America and or the people that
come to America everyone can be American
you come here and it's the Melting Pot
blah blah
that's something that is that has been a
an integral part of the United States's
story you know for the vast majority of
of our history and so I think that he
wasn't I think that it was just the
situation of he is kind of a normie yeah
and people are applying a lot of uh
extremely online context to a guy that
doesn't is totally unfamiliar with I
love it you know why he's a normie yeah
he said very Normy things Fat Cats in
Washington they're bad fat people on
welfare are exploiting our taxes and the
left attacked him and the right cheered
for him that says a whole lot about what
these factions are the Democrats are the
party of the wealthy Elites and they
were offended by what he said yeah and
the right is a disparate group of people
of varying ideologies for the most part
that are anti-establishment anti-woke
and and generally agree to disagree I
mean when we do this show the left calls
it right wing despite the fact we have
people of all different political
backgrounds having conversations so this
guy represents just a regular dude he
lives in a trailer he's out down south
in Virginia I I love his videos he's got
one where he's in front of a river and
he's just playing the song ain't got a
dollar and I'm like and the Train's
going by he's gotta wait for the train
that's super cool just a regular dude
who wrote this song that had some good
lyrics I Wish politicians would look out
for minors and not just a minor on an
island somewhere I mean like yeah he
kind of just hit the nail on the head
with the hammer with a lot of the stuff
and uh you know I like folk so for me
it's easy yeah but uh I think a lot of
people when you watch him perform and
you see the people in the audience like
nodding along to it he's speaking to
just regular people right that's the
thing I don't understand is we're
getting mad at him when he's like
they're like oh most people are pretty
you know middle middle of the road most
people think like pretty pretty Center
the way ideas and everyone's mad at him
from well not everyone but some people
are mad at him on the right like we've
just seen here and people on the left
from Adam it's like this is what most
people think like you guys should all be
championing him because this is what
most people think he's the American and
I'm not so sure that he is uh it's funny
they call him Anthony even though his
name is Chris was a Lunsford or
something yeah yeah is it Lunsford Chris
Anthony Chris Anthony Lunsford is his
name they call him Anthony because
Oliver Anthony's his base his stage
performance name or whatever his
grandfather but uh I gotta tell you I
don't think he's super politically
active he says the middle middle the
road kind of guy but he's also the kind
of guy that was activated by Donald
Trump a regular guy who's just like you
know what man let the molotov cocktail
ball in China shop go
in 2016 when I went to all of Trump's
campaign rallies were exactly like this
guy yeah they told me that they were not
Republicans they hated Republicans they
were not conservative but they hated the
politicians they hated the political
establishment and they just wanted Trump
to do something dude Trump gave people
fire to like break up the Deep State he
was so excited about draining the swamp
and it didn't have he put John Bolton in
and he got all these weirdos involved
and didn't do it because he didn't know
how or he believed the Liars like he
believed the I just but he did light a
fire under people's ass like he woke
people up that there was an
administrative State I think most of the
United States people didn't even realize
that we were being run by bureaucrats at
the time so I will give him that and
maybe yeah if he if he woke Oliver up
that's a huge deal whenever no I don't
think he woke up Oliver individually I'm
saying it's people like him that are
considered the Forgotten demographic
when it comes to voting whenever Trump
says you know they're not coming after
me they're coming after you know the
people who support me the people who
sort of are behind me I think this whole
story is sort of an example of that you
know you just detailed how his how his
rise really is an entire Fu not just to
like the music industry but just to The
Establishment as a whole what he sings
about who he is just as a person so it's
like they have to character assassinate
him I don't know if you guys saw but
they had pulled up some old like YouTube
videos that he had liked trying to
allege he was some crazy conspiracy
there so I think this just goes to show
how it's like you know Must Destroy
Oliver Anthony because he represents
everything that we oppose and I think it
goes back to what we were talking about
earlier you know they love to
artificially create all these divisions
whether it's the race the gender the sex
you know I'm sure I don't have to
enumerate all those for the people who
watch this show but I think the biggest
lie in terms of division that we've been
sold really is Republican Democrat
because I think that orientation of the
world is just is so wrong because it's
people like Oliver Anthony and its
people it's basically the people who
listen to Oliver Anthony's music and
feel like they have a voice and what he
singing about and the people who listen
to his music and are like oh my God he's
singing about me and I think that's sort
of the line that represents like the two
factions in this country maybe faction
is a harsh word but um they have to
destroy him because he represents
everything well I think the factions
many people describe them in many
different ways the two parent factions
but it's really just are you in the cult
are you not yeah 100 that's that's just
all it is because like
you know there was this viral video
going around where dude's wearing uh
Biden for Resident shirt or something
like that and he's talking to two
liberals who don't realize he hates he
doesn't like Joe Biden and he's asking
them questions and then whenever he just
says something about Biden that is bad
they're like that's not sure where'd you
hear that and he's like he's like in the
news and then it was funny he was like
well Biden's taking bribes and engaging
corrupt business and they're like
where's your evidence for that and then
he lists off all of these things that'll
come out the IRS whistleblowers the
barisma video and like he just keeps
going and then they're like I don't
believe any of that it's just like okay
you're in a couple belief it's it's
beliefs the words right there they give
it to you
um
the uh we were uh when you were saying
we were talking about diversity that
term that he used diversity and I we
talked about this before the show a
little bit that what's happening is I
don't want to say the Communists because
it might not just be Communists that are
doing this but people are twisting
definitions in the Modern Age definition
the word feminism definition of the word
diversity definition of uh Equity yeah
that's all that's all communism yeah the
definition of the word pandemic like
what the Spanish Flu was a pandemic I
didn't see that happen to people this
time during but uh
so if if you buy into the the Twisted
definition of the word diversity you're
going to fall into this like thinking
he's a bad guy because you believe the
enemies uh twist the definition of your
own material like don't buy the
don't don't fall into the game of the of
the twisting of language right now right
don't believe the Communists yeah is it
just Communists I probably is it's
people that want a lot of things to
share the Communist right now the the
left more broadly but they share our uh
our lexicon but they don't share our
dictionary no exactly they've used the
same words that we use but the meanings
that they apply to them uh are different
and some of them when you're dealing
with the the more consequentialist type
uh they will use both meanings so for
instance they'll use the term rate like
they'll say racism like if you talk
about racism they'll say well that's not
racism because racism is is Prejudice
plus power right but then later on in
the comments conversation they'll use
the term racism and they'll mean bigotry
yeah so they'll use both definitions
which puts the person they're talking
with at a disadvantage because they're
literally confusing them intentionally
because they're not looking to resolve
the uh the conversation or they're not
looking to to converse with someone
they're not looking to collaborate
they're looking to prove the other
person wrong don't get a you know get
the clip or whatever pressure yeah but
they're not looking to collaborate on an
idea that produces something that is
actually productive they're looking to
compromise right yeah there's a funny
video I just saw where guys basically
saying you can't be liberal and punk
rock anymore because liberal is the
establishment and he's like so basically
to be punk rock you have to be
conservative which is kind of funny and
he goes I know a lot of you are going to
say yeah but they're Christians and you
go and he's like well but that makes you
the bigot
hey we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click join us become a member to support
our work directly it's greatly
appreciated and you get access to our
uncensored members only show which will
be live in about 30 minutes and we talk
about things that aren't so family
friendly
and you know so earmuffs for your kids
maybe put them to bed and then we take
your calls you guys call in and talk to
us and the guest but let's read your
super chats all right
I'm not your buddy guy with the first
Super Chat says I rarely agree with Ian
but he is right yesterday now is the
time for a civil disobedience we cannot
allow these mandates to come back not
only for the economy but for society's
sake non-violent civil disobedience is
the key there is several ways to go
about Victory and uh procedural we need
more Scott pressler's we need more voter
registration we need ballot harvesting
operations where legal and we need
people to when appropriate engage in
peaceful non-violent Civil Disobedience
and you have to be very very very
tactful about it I'm very very careful
and very very planned these leftist
organizations have been doing this for
decades they have lawyers they have
multiple legal Observer non-profits they
plan these things out months in advance
you can't just show up and wave a sign
you've gotta you gotta you gotta make
sure you're doing everything by the book
all right I'm not your guy friend says
we need a new drinking game for every
time Biden falls asleep on camera
yep
ready to rumble says Oliver Anthony just
uploaded a new song I want to go home
it's called and it's amazing it is
pretty good uh Richmond north of
Richmond is it really is his best but I
really do like uh ain't got a dollar
uh you know I'm just I I just I'm a big
fan of acoustic folk kind of music so uh
not big on country but the overlap is
easy enough for me with this year that
uh it's you know I dig it
fatty Tang says shout out to Dave Smith
for his new comedy special yeah check
out Dave Smith's new comedy special we
should get him in here yeah
definitely that'd be great
we will grab some more Super chats
HS Disturbed says how do we get
Independent Media closer to these
politicians and elitist a-holes the
mainstream media won't ask the questions
that need to be answered tell Luke
gradkowski to get back into the game you
see Luke used to be running up to these
guys and asking them questions and uh we
need a new generation of lucrutkowskis
who are doing that groundwork you can
also if you seem aloof uh they'll invite
you to come hang out with them because
they'll they'll actually believe you are
part of them if you seem like aloof
enough so you kind of that's what a lot
part of this Jester character that I
have created and stuff like oh I'm just
having a fun loving like yeah they'll
invite you in and then you can work from
the inside
here's a good one MJ the bemj says I
work at AMC we just replaced all of our
Bud Light with Yingling let's go nice
nice right on
Heron gaming news says I bought the
Appalachian nights Brew I must say it
was well worth the two-week wait I'm
watching this while sipping on Casper
dude it's good Appalachian nice is my
favorite coffee of all time I could I
could just I every morning I'm just like
chugging it it's so good this morning
I'd rise with Roberto Jr which is also
really really good and I think what
we're doing now is
we're going to be doing re-rise with
Roberto Jr as a limited seasonal run it
uh we'll have more information on it but
it's a it's custom art and we're doing 5
000 of them and that's it there's only
that's we're gonna do it one time and
then we're gonna uh prepare a bunch of
specific uh Blends promo ones we're
gonna we'll always have the originals
but what I'm really looking forward to
is I think we briefly talked to Alex
Stein about this
but we're also getting ready uh we're
we're starting the initial phases of
Alex Stein 99 Prime Time grind two times
caffeine
so I'm drinking that for sure yeah I
kind of felt like that's appropriate for
uh for the Alex Stein Hebrew with Red
Bull no I don't know about that that
might break your coffee maker but uh we
would do you know the and then we're
working on the Sheamus blind as well we
have the art going for that and I really
think this is a a really cool way to go
about
marketing teaming up with other other
people giving them a cut of they get a
percentage of all sales it goes to them
and then they have their unique blend
through us and we do it that way a
collaborative way to build up and then
uh when we launch the physical location
it is their shows that we will have so
you might walk in and see Alex Stein's
video playing and then you see his
coffee right there ready to drink that's
cool yeah so it's all about we got we
got to confirm that with uh with Alex
Stein though but I'm really excited to
be really funny to see him like go to
Plano Texas before like the city council
or whatever he does holding up a bag of
coffee with him on it and being like why
am I
just say something says way to go
timcast you got the YouTube covid Badge
Of Truth tonight yeah yeah also heart
Natalie
yep there you go to the title yup yup
that's right that's right you put that
in the title update from where the
earlier vote Kamala or Joe Biden for
president and like everyone said Biden I
don't think anyone said Kamala maybe a
few people did I missed it but uh that's
shocking just a dad says Ian just rolled
a million twenties
Joshua says Ian just wrote the 21 how is
this possible
and cracked it open God of warmth says
new Primal Ian is awesome get angry hell
yeah yes something we should we should
it's all the working out Primal Ian
coffee blend yes Primal and he's like uh
dude that's hard
just get like a picture of my back he's
going soupy on the back just like the
muscles of my back for this last week
before the final shoot we're having Ian
drink a pint of Ben and Jerry's oh God
no no we we did change though I'm gonna
be doing just raw cream and milk it's
really good
nutmeg uh I don't think so I don't even
need it because it's already Sweet the
milk's sweet no no that that cream thing
in the fridge you're talking about I did
have some of that too I mixed all three
together yeah there's Maple in there
that's ice cream mix yeah so so what
that is it's raw organic cream with a
little bit with uh raw organic milk
raw organic vanilla I don't know if it's
raw it's vanilla extract from a farm
with raw organic maple syrup and in
additional it's just like nature right
there for you I've been supplanting my
diet with a company called factor that
they do pre-made ready meals you guys
are awesome I love Factor meals what a
great great company I would whatever are
they like they're like ready to Maiden
ready-made two minutes in the microwave
and it's not obviously microwaving is
not the best but when I'm I gotta eat a
lot so it's just like grab go grab go
grab go every Monday yeah maybe we do an
order for the for everybody spectacular
the fridge and grab one because we do
that with uh with another company that
they actually sponsored us one time I
think and Factory if you guys I will
shout you guys out every night on this
show I mean Tim obviously runs the ads
and stuff but yeah I shot it out because
it's good and it is so healthy so
delicious and then I put a big lump of
sour cream on top let's get back to
Super chats I like the the Super Chat
from Chase that says Ian just broke the
die to reveal a 21 inside that's awesome
codes
Paul thong thong cam says I live in
Texas every now and then I see someone
still wearing masks entering stores
while everyone else has nothing yeah
we're Frozen completely oh there we go
and it just came back dude Collins is f
oh that was weird what's up guys Colin
says F yeah in the chat so like he it'll
it'll pop back in a second I wonder
where it'll pick up hey look we're back
we're back it's whatever we're like near
the end of the show did you hear Tim
reveal it yeah people are saying YouTube
shut down you were just about to
compliment me man what happened that
sucked no that this was uh this was not
on YouTube's end we can tell if it's
YouTube or us this time it was on yeah
so when I say us it's like nothing here
I think something happened somewhere in
the wilderness maybe like
an animal got electrocuted and then
shuts the internet landed on an open
wire somewhere yep maybe what were you
saying you're saying something awesome
about me
the post-millennial retweeted it too oh
did they yeah I'm going to retweet it
right now I hope the post millennial
makes a lot of money off of reposting
our Clips that's a good I was like when
you I was feeling it and I ran out of
breath and I just keep kept talking if
you're if you're angry and you're
running out of breath keep talking don't
take a deep breath you don't need it I
was I was thinking about this
like people there's a bunch of people
who are like I made this much money on
Twitter and are on X or whatever and
then I I saw a lot of people saying like
yeah I take clips from you know Tim cast
iron I post them I'm making money off it
and I was like
that's kind of a good thing like I don't
I'm not mad about that like if if people
think that they can take clips from this
show and post them to generate lots of
traffic and it makes them money that's
free advertising yeah extremely for
Humanity like that's I want to make a
song it's like a number one hit like
everyone share the clips share the clips
make more and then you'll get the idea
of Twitter if we could create a song or
a TV like a song that's one of the best
on Earth and then make it free for
everyone like no one owns it and all
these people will clip it and remix it
and make movies with it and like that's
all that matters is that it's there you
know I I wrote a song you know a new one
it's called poor man south of Portland
and I'm really excited for it
because I went to Portland Maine and you
know I just got me thinking these
actually you know it would be a really
funny parody song song called poor men
south of Portland and it's not poor as
in uh like lacking money it's these poor
politicians who are being smeared by
these awful Maga fascists yeah and it's
just you sing the song from the
perspective of rain Wilson and his other
Democrat elitist Buddies
there you go
Clint Torres says
if there's an Airborne Ebola it's going
to get in your house just like covet did
yeah yeah but the idea is like don't go
out and seek it but ultimately it's just
you make the choice man you're getting
your house not mine like if there was
lava in the street like imagine every
single Street and every city turned to
molten lava and they're like sorry you
can't leave your house because there's
molten love outside but that's my choice
you literally can't at that point if
it's literally yeah you would be like
your house yeah it's a very different
situation I'm just saying if like it was
a major disaster I think it's funny when
there are storms and they're like
everyone evacuate it's like you don't
really have to but you should yeah you
know what I mean but they don't it's
pretty I I maybe they do I'm not I don't
know I'm pretty sure there's a lot of
areas where they're like people will
just stay and then they're like okay but
there's no rescue for you you know what
I mean
there's times when uh when there's
floods that they do that they're like
okay look everyone get out everyone get
out and if you don't leave when the
actual uh like when hurricanes move
through when the Hurricane's moving
through there's a certain amount of time
when they're like you're on your own we
can't get to you while the Hurricanes
you know coming after the hurricane we
might be able to or when it dies down or
whatever you know but there are times
where the government's like you're on
your own and they will let you know when
that happens Gunner Anderson says Tim my
state for Hurricane Ida category four
there was massive amounts of heavy rain
and tornadoes that ripped through my
yard tropical storms and low category
storms are just a drizzle anything
beyond that category two hold on to your
britches yes I was talking about this
when I was in Sandy and Irene I think
they were both category ones
like nothing Irene was funny because it
was just
cloudy and windy and and it was just
windy and like there were tree branches
in the street and I'm like how long ago
was Irene oh this was 20
12 maybe no no this had to be 2010. okay
yeah maybe 2010 let me let me let me
look it up
while you do that I want to give a shout
out to vash's Dad who's in my mentions
mad at me because I dunked on his kid
2011. really drunk on him really good is
that why uh because I pointed out the
whole like uh blush vosh has this clip
out there where he goes and he uh I
criticize him a lot for being a
consequentialist there's this clip out
there where vosh goes and he says that
I'm I'm I don't want to lose for
socialism I want to win for socialism
what he's saying is I'm going to lie and
be dishonest because I don't want to
yeah
win at all costs and I put it up there
and I criticized him and then then wash
his dad is like don't pick on my baby
boy see he said baby boy no he didn't
really do it he but he but I mean when a
dude comes in to defend his adult dad
his adult kid who's a millionaire
streamer and the dude rolls in because
he's mad because I criticize his kid who
for admitting that he is a liar bro get
out of my mentions dude beat it you know
I got I gotta be honest man the left
makes a lot of really good points they
really do uh I typically loathe uh I say
typically but you hear me out they're
all when I encounter your average
wealthy person they are not pleasant
people and I gotta tell you when these
leftists complain about white people
here's the reality though they're
talking about themselves yeah like these
Upper Crust Urban white liberals it's
like bro everything you say you know
what fine have it that's you dude yeah
like that vosh is describing himself
yeah there ain't nobody that's more
white supremacist than uh that woman
that wrote White for jelly yeah it's
like right when I talk about the Nazis
there's probably like the people that
are wearing black or marching the
streets yeah all chanting one thing at
the same time like all have one main
ideology they're trying to impress on
everybody else huh interesting okay
let's grab some more Super chats
what do we got Dylan bellu says Ian can
I borrow that jacket for one of my best
friend's wedding Saturday rolling
twenties homie if I could if you were
here I'd let you grab it
I feel here's what he wants to hear
Sergeant Buck says I'm against poverty
okay great can you find me someone who
is actively in favor of poverty depends
on who you're talking about there are
people that I want to see poor
these poor men south of Portland
what do we got
Stephen Sanders says Tim I was arrested
December 12 2022 in Florida three hours
in handcuffs I share Ian's passion I'm a
retired veteran in love with freedom
right on right on
where are we at
someone making fun of Fanny Willis
that's very funny uh what do we have the
squid says don't forget that the
original language hidden in the
Affordable Care Act allowed for
euthanasia of the old with the likely
intent to move on to disabled people
with or people with mental health issues
well
it's happening in Canada so you know
definitely oh I'm just rolling a stone
around in my head when people are like
oh you know you should like that on
camera oh no don't clip it don't clip it
definitely sorry so what are we saying
um the whole like the like you I think
that you should be able to end your own
life without worrying about like the you
know
any kind of legal issues but the the
problem with that is it's the government
can't help but try to encourage people
the government can't help but be
horrible it's like if there is a
horrible outcome expect the government
to do it you know they're going to test
syphilis stuff on people they're on you
know they're going to test uh drugs on
people without their no knowledge
they're they're going to do all kinds of
Nefarious horrible that's why you
can't let the government have you got to
keep the government as small as you can
that's why we the people are the
government in this country this
experiment you cannot put the power in a
small group of hands because it always
becomes corrupt throughout the history
of time so this is the experiment I was
we govern ourselves join in
all right Christopher Grover says seeing
Andy knows Victory yesterday gave me a
lot of Hope as a portlander maybe
there's still hope for this city we're
not beaten yet
I mean maybe people gotta stand up they
gotta vote they gotta push back if
Portland went Republican I would not be
surprised I wouldn't uh there's there's
an element of surprise I could say like
wow it finally happened but the reality
is
hearing what's been going on there I
wouldn't be surprised if a bunch of
regular local residents or just like
please make it all stop but I think for
the reality is most people just leave
abandoning the city instead yeah I mean
the people that have the means to get
out like there's not a whole lot
especially considering there's not a
whole lot holding people in one place
anymore especially considering the fact
that the the uh that kovid and the
lockdowns and stuff kind of showed a lot
of people that they have options and and
other ways to live their lives that are
not going to a nine to five all the time
and and remote is an option for some for
more people I think the name realize
that one gamer says Larry Elder is
filing an emergency injunction to get on
the debate stage after meeting the
requirements and still being denied I'm
curious to watch this play out thoughts
love it I think they're claiming that uh
one of the polls he used was affiliated
with Donald Trump therefore he's it's no
longer it's not valid or whatever but
the only issue is that like Trump's
campaign
sponsored a poll which is what everyone
does you'll see a poll and it'll say
like ABC news ipsos or whatever like and
it's because the news organization will
go to them and say hey we're gonna pay
for you to do this poll the polling is
then done and it's in conjunction with
yeah I think uh Larry Elder should be on
the debate stage
yeah I agree
where are we at Griffin Street Studios
as I signed up with my State's RNC today
to gather votes in coming months stop
what you're doing and join me can't
expect anything take action now you're
here yeah
Jason static says Trump Vivek team
shirtless 2024. I don't know about Trump
shirtless
yeah actually no I want to see Trump
sure let's be hilarious Shadow Zero says
vivekis Bruce Banner to Trump's Hulk
that's actually pretty good
you know yeah yeah
here we go Jay trick penifer jatric
penifer says fantasy politics draft
Trump as president to be the aggro meat
Shield Tucker as vp'd have more attack
to Vegas Secretary of State to have
actual power over policy and RFK
Junior's attorney general because his
litigation history shows he'll go after
the corrupt
okay yeah
it's a pretty good roster hopefully
saddle effing Trump says come on
Tim Biden did poop himself in front of
the Pope he probably did
you know oh we got a good one I like
this one where is this uh
uh Rosa Morata says that's not fetterman
look at the ears oh I just want to
explain to people how uh depth of field
works so if there's a photo taken for a
portrait of John fetterman it's going to
smash his face and widen it out and if
you'd use a different kind of lens it
will narrow the face in the ears so it
really just depends on the lens but uh I
saw that going around and I was like
look at his nose look at his forehead
look at his eyes it's fetterman it's not
it's like not I mean I shouldn't even
have to say that you should be able to
look at it oh yeah
you know
where are we at
all right let's see Russian colluders is
not sure if things change with Escape
contests but if they won't take your 20
000 you should host the first annual
Roberto Junior memorial skate attorney
well uh we do have some developments I
don't know for sure but for those that
aren't familiar I posted that I'd be
putting twenty thousand dollars towards
a local do-it-yourself skateboard uh uh
jam session and contest in Martinsburg
West Virginia
they have rejected the the money
and so
I don't I don't I you know I I I don't
want to step on anybody's toes here but
I'm assuming I guess the the people of
Martinsburg West Virginia and the
skateboarders who are planning on coming
down don't want the money don't want the
the twenty thousand thousand prizes so
I'll have more information tomorrow when
I figure out what's going on but we may
just cancel it outright because if the
organizers are like don't bring your
twenty thousand dollars to our event I
am not going to fight anybody over me
giving away twenty thousand dollars but
in the meantime we decided
whether this happens or not we're going
to do our own event anyway and it's
going to be total DIY random we're not
going to do any kind of like putting up
tents and getting speakers literally
we're gonna do an event where we have
prizes and we just show up one day to
one of these parks and we'll tell
everyone where it is it may be in a week
or two so it's looking like
you know for whatever reason these
people who run this uh this DIY Plaza
don't want twenty thousand dollars I
can't tell you why but I don't know you
can always find out who wins and then
the following week just show up at their
house well that's what I was saying I
was like for what purpose would they be
like no don't bring your money here
because if I just showed up
they would be like here's the guy who
won I could write him a check and be
like here's the prize
so it was just like when they were like
we don't want your money I'm like okay
and I'll take it up like I don't know
take it up with the skateboarders who
are there if they didn't want the money
then far be it for me to tell them
they're for they have to take it my only
guess is if they were like oh a guy
on the internet just announced they were
here and they were getting a thousand
randoms this is not good that's the only
thing I can think of that they would say
no because it I could see saying no to
that if Mr Beast I don't shout it out
only yes the only guess no I completely
disagree with you mentioned that it
could be political but it doesn't strike
I completely disagree with that because
typically what happens when someone
contacts you and says we have an offer
for sponsorship you say what are the
details you don't say no because was it
did they know it was announced online
because that there's a lot of people
listening but but either way I mean the
response typically is hey like if Mr
Beast reached out and said there's
nothing it's like hey here really
appreciate it like what did you have in
mind here's what we could do here's what
makes sense here's it doesn't make sense
hey we can't do it that way we can do it
this way but the outright three-person
messaging our our uh one of our guys a
definitive like no at this same time
three different people associated with
the event I'm just like okay like all
right I mean
I I don't know what the reason is it
would be badass if you still got those
people the money the skaters that'd be
awesome I'm I'm not I'm not gonna show
up to someone's event when they were
like how dare you give money to the
locals yeah don't even go don't even
mention that you gave it to them no
we're gonna stay mind our own business
and just say okay guys fine whatever
slide that money into their bank
accounts nah we're just gonna not gonna
do it like there's there's there's got
to be if these are the guys that are
running the space and they're outright
like get out of here then I'll buy land
next door we'll build our own DIY Park
yeah and then we'll do our own event
it's like you do your thing like I'm you
know we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
build our own thing
whatever if like you know skate
skateboarders can ask anybody who's
going to that event you can ask them
what the issue was I guess I don't know
whatever all right here we go Michael
beacon says John fetterman looks like
he's in the he's in witness protection
like he's going to say no sir I am not
John fetterman I'm John uh I'm not John
fetterman I'm John fetterman by the way
thanks for the shout out Friday seven
Legions issue three coming soon glad to
hear it yeah
where are we at
do not do not infringe says the
Republican Party embracing Financial
conservatism a limited morality from the
equation and made the love of the root
of all evil and acceptable position
hence a Republican party that props up
candidates that are for sale the love of
money being the root of all evil I think
is what what you meant to type there the
word money didn't come in
the the money is not the root of all
evil the love of money is yeah
greed Rock bras says the brics bank
president is the former Brazilian
president Dilma Rousseff oh really wow
she wrecked Brazil Brazilian economy
further than covid there's no chance for
Brick Skies
wow yeah I mean look this is Africa we
can't even keep the lights on so I heard
that China's in Dire Straits as well
they're not they're not doing too hard
after that flood and the way they
diverted everything into and they locked
their entire economy down like we kind
of shut stuff down but they just
shredded themselves dude look at
Shanghai everyone that was like Shanghai
was like New York of China and everyone
that lived there that was not from China
which is like a large population of like
expats they don't live there anymore
they all left so yeah
all right Greg dubier says Doug burgum
is North Dakota governor he is a good
Governor but he would not be a good
president no idea why he's running yeah
I didn't even know who he was yeah it's
like I don't I don't know every single
governor and I have no idea why I should
be interested in hearing him argue with
Nikki Haley what what it what is this
it's it's insane yeah it's it's
completely irrelevant to American
politics
I can't I people are going to watch that
debate
I don't know okay so do you guys know
that there's the lesser-known candidates
debates
yeah there's like a famous viral video
of Vermin Supreme there was a democratic
debate and he glitter bombs one of the
candidates and these were like Democrats
who are running for president but no one
cares who they are the lesser-known
debates or whatever so there's a tiny
room go back to the Democrats but my
point is like this debate Fox News is
doing is like it's like it's like
watching
um
The Return of Jafar right you know you
go to the movie theaters to watch
Aladdin and you're like wow this is a
Disney classic and then later they have
a made for home VHS called Return of
Jafar they're like okay you know the
kids might want to watch it but it's not
a big billion dollar production in movie
theaters and they get impersonators for
the uh right they can't exactly there's
like it's not really you know uh Robin
Williams didn't reprise his roles Genie
and they got a sound alike and you know
and that's what this debate is
it's just like the lesser-known
candidates who are not going to win yeah
what is the what is the point I don't
know all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and head
over to timcast.com click join us become
a member because the members only show
starts in just a few minutes and as a
member if you sign up for at least six
months or if you sign up at the 25 per
month level you can submit questions and
even call into the show to talk to us
and our guest so do that you can follow
the show at timcastirl you can follow me
personally everywhere on X or on
Instagram and anywhere else at timcast
and uh Natalie join us anything out uh
you can find me on war room you can
follow me on Twitter at Natalie G
Winters right on I am Phil Labonte the
band is All That Remains you can follow
me on Twitter I'm at Phil that remains
I'm Phil that remains official on
Instagram uh like I said the band is All
That Remains you can find us on Apple
music Spotify on YouTube Pandora
Amazon music all over the place man all
over the yo Ian Crossland checking out
for the night had a great night good to
see you again Nat always pleasure and
remember you stand up for your rights so
you still have them tomorrow
nice that Crystal did he in so much
power today it's cool to see him that's
what it was it was the crystal blue
grotowski dude
with that powerful energy I mean think
about it like the way Luke normally acts
in the show too like yeah that wasn't
intentional either that's just real yeah
Luke is like sitting in his room right
now with a crystal ball and he's like
and he sees the end and it's like the
energy is flung into the creek
that was Luke that did it yeah
yeah anyways I am uh surge.com uh you
can catch me on x.com talk to you guys
soon we will see you all over at
timcast.com in a few minutes thanks for
hanging out